Yay.
Yes,
that's it.
We live.
That's live.
What's up baby?
How you doing?
You doing good to see a brother that is
a very colorful,
you've got a lot going on with that
shirt.
What's happening?
Fish it fishermen's outfit.
Is that what it is?
It's a,
it's an old nautica shirt I found.
Oh,
it's like,
it's a shirt that has pictures of rain
gear hanging up on hooks and binoculars
and boots and nets and shit.
Very,
it's a very powerful shirt.
Nautical theme shirt.
Yeah.
It's like a,
like a nautical shed where you put your
nautical gear.
Ice Fishing I think.
Do you fish?
I did in Orlando.
Used to fish a lot.
Yeah.
I was like,
I couldn't do it.
I couldn't party for a couple of years.
I get tested so I just went fishing
after school instead of partying instead
of partying.
Well you getting tested for just,
you know,
like your probation officer was show up
at your crib or whatever.
What'd you do to get you a probation
officer?
I had a,
I had like a,
I think we talked about this before.
I had like an assault,
like my second year of college,
I caught an assault charge,
but it was self defense and assault,
self defense,
self defense.
So I plan out,
but um,
no,
me and my buddy justin forming like a
quote and go party.
But he would come pick me up and we just
go fishing on the lakes and shit.
So Orlando's got really good bass
fishing.
No,
it really does.
I love fish.
I'm weighing a bass fishing.
I'll building like large mouth.
Yeah,
large mouth.
I do the rubber worms,
like the frogs off the lily pads.
Spinnerbaits all that jazz crank baits,
little Rapala,
little minnows and shit.
Mine was the watermelon seed worms that
bounce off the,
off the,
that was what you do.
Did you ever get like one of those
boats,
those little bass boats with a flat
bottoms and you can move around with a
little trolling motor.
So what we did was I had a canoe,
I had a canoeist decrypt,
but then on the other leg we saw this,
uh,
onboard voter that the dude had just
left on his dock.
So one night we were,
we were younger.
It was like high school where I was,
so we stole this dude's and boat and put
it on my canoe.
So we were cruising with the fucking,
the,
the onboard motor on my canoe.
How did you install it on a canoe?
Because it couldn't do as a pointy end
as opposed to a flat end.
I Dunno.
My boy,
justin figured it out.
I have no idea how he fucking did it,
but it doesn't make any sense.
He rigged it up to put it on the back of
the shit,
but cause it couldn't,
it has two points as a point in the
front and appoint in the back.
Yeah.
How,
how the hell do you get a motor back
there?
He did it.
I have no idea.
He called it the,
was it a,
um,
a trolling motor,
like a real quiet one or was it a big
heavy,
like it was the quiet little one.
You can put it on the front,
right?
That little little thing.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The idea of those is you want to like
almost kind of go against uh,
the,
uh,
like of a titus pulling you one way or
the the,
you know,
or move along the bank.
You know,
you're in freshwater use them.
Actually they're probably only using
fresh water cause you could creep into
the lily pads with,
so we'd creep in and there was like a
drop off on this lake,
on the Butler chain and like around
sundown,
just fish would just be right there.
If you get to the drop off,
you could hit them.
I love fishing,
so it's fun.
It's something primal about it.
There's something primal about like when
you catch something and you see it,
like when you're like,
how can I want to go on a gallon?
Then as it's coming up,
you see it in the water.
Like who they are.
It is,
yeah.
Oh my goodness.
It,
I think it goes back to like ancient DNA
or something.
Yeah,
it's,
it's also you just,
you can feel the life on the line,
you know,
you can feel it.
But I was a catch and released.
I used to eat them,
but then I started feeling bad because I
was going out every day.
So I just,
I let them go.
If you really feel bad,
don't catch and release because when you
catch and release a lot of them die.
That's the dirty secret about catch and
release fishing.
Kind of creepy because like I went
salmon fishing and this is really kind
of brought home to me when I went salmon
fishing,
me and the Rx your fear a couple of
years ago and went up to Alaska and uh,
when we were like write more,
getting up there,
they had turned it into catch and
release because they have like a salmon
weird,
you know what a weirder is.
It's like,
um,
they have these,
uh,
sort of a patch pathways that the salmon
have to go through and they set them up
so they can add,
they can accurately count how many
salmon go through at any given time.
So they can estimate how strong the
schools are that are coming upstream and
downstream.
So they can ask teammate pretty,
pretty accurately how many salmon are in
the river,
what the populations are,
how healthy they are.
So the salmon,
we're there,
it goes right there,
you can see it.
Um,
they got like right before we're going
up there,
they got poor numbers and uh,
it was kind of ironic because the day we
got there,
the numbers were off the fucking charts.
We got there at like one of the best
days for salmon fishing ever.
But we had to let them all go.
It was real weird.
Um,
but we were catching the shit.
One of them,
they didn't even know,
well,
no,
we couldn't keep any of them.
Um,
we call a rainbow trout.
I got to keep,
that was pretty rare.
You don't really get to any rainbows up
there.
I put the salmon were giant.
Well,
we were catching them all day and
releasing them,
but you release him,
you're like,
that's one of the four grand going
America,
you know,
you see some fun kills deeper than the
lifting and stuff like that.
But I felt,
I felt I'll write about my out,
get them,
get them out of the lip.
But you're right.
Sometimes if they swallowed the bait,
if they swallow the bait,
I'd take it.
And you know,
if it was in the lip,
I let it go.
Well,
some fishes don't taste that good
either.
That's the thing about large mouth bass.
Delicious fish.
Yeah.
That's fucking cat food bro.
Like as Kamin Salmon's a delicious fish,
but a large mouth bass.
It's like,
yeah,
I guess I could eat this.
Your salt water fish,
man.
I'll keep them.
If they're the right size,
You could freeze them whatever they
delicious.
But freshwater fish man.
I mean,
except for trout there trout tastes
really good.
Yeah,
that's a,
is that brackish water?
No.
Um,
most trout are fresh water,
but uh,
there are some brackish water,
like steelheads I think you'd go into
the ocean,
you know,
isn't that correct?
I think steelheads make it into the
ocean.
Um,
or they get at least close to it.
Definitely get into brackish water.
Salmon of course.
Go back and forth.
He's still fish out here.
Yeah,
man,
I love fishing.
Um,
different places.
uh,
there's uh,
for freshwater there's Lake castaic
which is nice.
They have a lot of actual,
uh,
they actually striped bass,
which are great.
It's all fresh water.
It's,
it's,
it's kind of an artificial lake.
Um,
but right now they're hurting because
this drought that we've had up here for
the last few years,
like it used to,
we used to film fear factor up there and
uh,
especially there's this plate called to,
to hone ranch.
This is the most shocking.
There's this place called the home ranch
that had this beautiful lake for large
mouth bass and we used to drop people on
fear factor at a helicopters in this
lake.
Now the lake is completely dry.
There is nothing in the lake.
It's dead,
totally dry,
completely flat.
You could see the bottom of it and it
was a mass fish die off.
And they said there was some beautiful,
huge 10 plus pound bass that just died
in that lake of no air,
no water,
no nothing.
That's crazy.
So you to see it in the lake.
It just dead fish everywhere is not,
well now you can't cause all the birds
picked him off and it's all gone because
it's been like that for over a year.
But it just completely dried up.
No water.
When a lake dries up,
it's just Thanksgiving for birds.
Yeah.
Well for a little while.
Damn.
Birds get diarrhea.
Sad man.
They must get diarrhea,
right?
They'd probably eat anything.
No birds can date a lot of shit.
I mean,
they eat a lot of shit off my patio.
I dropped food.
I throw it out there,
man.
Seagulls eat anything.
So a how you like him west coast.
Live in baby.
I'm into,
you know what like fuck the wind still.
Um,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm way into living out here.
I'm not into the people as much yet.
I'm still like,
I like New York people.
I like,
I like haters.
You know what I mean?
New York,
I hate us.
You like,
Hey,
I love haters.
I was telling a friend,
New York's got people,
you do well.
People in New York one hates you.
You do well in La,
people just want to work for you.
And I'm like,
get,
oh go away.
Go Away.
Cool.
I'd rather you hate me and criticize me.
And then I know like what to work on,
you know?
Interesting.
And I like criticism,
man.
It just reminds me of my mother.
That's funny man.
So in what,
what?
Like how so like how,
like when you say that New York has more
haters,
like when you're doing,
when you becoming successful in New
York,
what you felt like,
like it's just a much more criticism.
Much more,
much more scrutiny.
Yeah.
It's never like,
Yo,
you did a great job.
It's like,
Yo,
that was all right man.
That was all right,
but let me tell you what you really need
to be doing.
And so people will actually put you on a
things and whatever.
I like criticism.
I like feedback.
I like it when it's valid and it's
coming from people that aren't retarded.
Agreed.
That's a problem.
Youtube hate not so much the most
entertainment.
Well,
here's the thing,
if you ever left a youtube comment,
yeah,
I talked to them all the time.
It's funny if you ever left a youtube
comment on something other than your own
videos.
Yeah.
Really?
You're rare.
Most peoples,
they watch you two videos and they enjoy
it or they don't enjoy it.
That's it.
They walk away,
they
move on with their life.
You're a rare dude in that case.
Yeah.
I think for the most part,
80% of the feedback's terrible,
but every once in a while a lot of our
lower thirds on the show,
like the nicknames we use and Shit,
it's like fans in the youtube comments
leave them and this is all the vice
stuff on the vice stuff.
On longs world.
Yeah.
Right.
So they give me,
they give me good suggestions and I'll
keep in touch with some of the people I
talk to on Youtube or instagram.
Commoners are pretty fucking good now
too.
Well,
except when they have their accounts
blocked.
It seems to me that like if you look at
90% of the comments on instagram when
you go to their accounts that blocked
the cowards.
Yeah.
Instagram is the land of the cowards.
Cause you can't do that shit.
Like you can't comment on someone else's
stuff in most forms unless they can go
to your stuff and look at you put an
Instagram,
they allow you that option.
And I think that they should take it
away.
They should take it away.
It should be,
you should own up to the things you were
saying.
Well here's my feeling.
If you,
if you're going to be private,
you shouldn't be allowed to comment.
Like if you're going to be private on
Instagram,
you shouldn't be allowed to just go on
other people's pages and shit all over
them.
Yeah.
Cause I've,
I've read Sangria but just mean nasty
fucking shit that people write on these
girls pages about what the girls look
like.
And I'm like well what does this mother
fucker look like?
Then I go,
cause all I could see of your face is
this like one eighth of a centimeter
face.
And so then I go to their page and it's
blocked.
I'll see on homegirls like pages and
stuff,
there's dudes are just like,
oh,
I want to come under titties and she's
like eating with our grandmother.
Do you know what I mean?
Look,
a lot of it,
a rude comment on the dumplings or
something.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
Well,
grandma had a nice dump look over there.
Especially if we're worried that the
grandma might actually look at the
picture with her granddaughter and
Village Fair out there trying to come
on.
My granddaughter's did.
Luckily my parents are only on facebook.
My parents are fucking killing facebook
now.
They see facebook is the most
transparent.
You can go right to someone's page and
you see exactly who they are and that's
a different animal.
You know the the instagrams weird in
that way.
Like some people don't even have a
photo,
you know,
you'd go to their instagram pages,
no photo.
Yeah,
it's all blocked up.
But then they just use it to comment on
people's pages and shit on them.
Youtube and instagram.
Like I said,
80% of it's terrible,
but it's always entertaining.
It's fucking super fucking entertaining.
Sometimes it's not an entertaining to me
because I feel like there's so much
spinning your wheels.
I like these,
these people that are like super mega
negative on these things like this.
You're not getting it.
No one's getting anywhere with this
people with lives,
but there's some good fucking jokes.
There's some comedians in the comments
been oh yeah,
definitely.
They got some fucking joke.
It's not all negative.
Yeah,
definitely not all negative,
but as far as like comments,
I would say like,
oh well instagram comments get to a good
joke.
I like it.
I'll go through miles of shit.
I would say instagram comments are
probably the best out of all [inaudible]
and Paul.
Twitter's pretty God damn good too.
I mean I'm real fortunate in that.
I would say that more than 99% of all
the interactions I have with people
online through social media or positive,
more than 99% it's probably
like 99.9 it's really good cause people
love you.
Mine is probably,
I think like 70 30 people love you to,
come on dude,
I put you up on instagram today and
people went crazy.
They super happy to have you back.
Thank you.
Take [inaudible] found out your
fisherman shirt was rocking it to ice.
Why Susan?
Gods?
You win a fitbit.
What the fuck is going on?
Fuck is going on.
My toast has got to get to the CONTOSO.
You know you're not going to get to get
close with a rubber band.
What do you eat?
Well,
I had a smoothie this morning.
What was in it?
There's no sugar.
It was just Alvin butter and Spirulina.
Oh.
Oh well you're coughing.
Just thinking about it.
The coffee man,
coffee got me the eye guys.
Spirit lead about protein powder.
Alman butter fucking dates.
That's all good.
Well the almond milk almond milk from a
store with a gang of sugar in it.
I don't know.
So I didn't ask.
See,
I'm new to this ketosis game,
right?
I was just getting into it.
I'm a rookie with,
well that ain't gonna make it most
almond milk that you buy from stores
unless you look real careful.
Like if you buy like vanilla almond
milk,
it's bullshit.
You might as well be just drinking a
chocolate shake.
Oh yeah,
this they're,
they're low.
Dunkin called me up,
dude.
I love almond milk.
It's the best man.
It's so delicious.
It's really good for you.
I go,
it's delicious.
Huh?
Um,
how many grams of sugars in it?
Oh,
I don't know.
Hold on.
19 I go,
yeah dude,
you're drinking sugar water,
drinking a glass of fucking,
by the way,
that's an eight ounce glass drinking
eight ounces.
One of those idiots,
man.
I'll wear this fitbit.
I'll tell myself I'm going to get in
shape and eat healthy all day.
And then last night I got,
I got drunk and I ended up eating like a
bag of chips and SMURF gummies,
you know,
so that's not,
that's not the ketosis.
Alcohol too.
Alcohol translates directly and sugar in
your body or transforms.
But I'd just like to tell myself that
I'm trying,
well,
what are you trying to do?
You're just trying to be healthier.
You're trying to lose weight.
I would like to go down a cup size.
A cut.
Yeah.
Kind of be like,
I'm like a 34 B,
you know Standard Cup size.
I'd like to be an a and a yeah.
If I could get to like 32 A.
I think it helped my basketball game
cause I got the dream killers now bro
down mbdl with the MTDL that the NBA
Development League you see?
Yeah.
Like anybody can,
anybody could see you could try out.
That's not going to work.
Come on.
My dream is I think you got a little run
our test and use some better way.
I'm going to go down a cup size of trial
for the oh man.
Hmm.
Okay.
Do this.
Do you play a lot of basketball?
I played a lot of basketball and
watching the knicks this year.
I just,
I feel like I could do some things for
them.
Addiction is so fucking terrible.
Yeah,
I could watch it and be terrible.
If they're in New York they have money.
Right.
It's a giant ass team.
Cause,
I mean there's a lot of bad things you
can buy with money like Carmelo Anthony.
Oh see bad,
terrible.
It makes me,
he had a good year this year,
but it's just like he,
he,
he's not terrible.
It's,
he's a bad fit for this team because he
needs to be on a winner.
And I'm like,
he reassigned with the knicks knowing it
was rebuilding team and he should be,
he should have gone to Chicago.
I want us,
she'd gone to Chicago or we should have
traded Carmelo for Blake Griffin.
That would have helped the clippers and
it would have helped the next,
this is a lot of technical talk and I'm
not really bad.
Not really hip to all right.
We'll move on to,
so you're just trying to be healthier is
where you're trying to do.
Um,
and you try to like a hoop dreams chill.
You do have what we still believe,
I still play ball.
I go to Ucla,
a play at ucla,
play at USC and I go to Montecito
heights rec center.
Monday,
Wednesday,
Fridays I got open run Montecito
Heights.
Where's that?
It's like Pasadena or drive an hour
every Monday,
Wednesday,
Friday mornings to go play ball.
Really?
I love it.
Wow.
Yeah.
Cause I all 30 like last year I was 30 I
just turned 34 like last month and last
year was the first year I was like,
Yo,
I actually got a lot worse at basketball
because I was getting incrementally
better and I was like,
Yo,
I think I'm getting old.
This was the first year I felt old.
I guarantee you it's just because you're
busy.
34 it's not old enough where your body
starts deteriorating.
Do you lift weights?
Yeah,
I do weights.
I do.
I apply on metrics.
Isometrics.
That's kind of doc can fuck with your w
a basketball game bat in a bad way.
I used to fuck with my pool game.
It was a big problem that I like to lift
weights,
but I also like to play pool and when
you lift a lot of weights,
you get sore and when you're sore and
stiff it fucks with your fine motor
skills.
It would really fuck with my pool game.
Yeah.
No,
my jumpers trash right now.
Yeah.
I think a lot of that has to do with
lifting weights.
It could work for a lot of people when
you're sore and you're like why all the,
you know how like I guess I don't play
basketball.
I'm and I'm terrible at it.
But I would imagine that it's similar to
pool in that you got to know exactly how
much effort to put on that ball.
Yeah,
exactly.
You know,
I know like when a crumple up the paper
and I throw it in a Trashcan,
it's a weird thing.
Right?
Cause you kind of estimating the drop,
you know the arc of that little thing.
You have to have this fine sense.
I'm a send this video to everyone on my
squad and be like,
guys you got to give me the Baltimore
shoot.
I'm just missing shots cause I'm too
strong now.
Lived in too many ways to switch over is
not wet too swollen to school.
I'm way too small for this game.
It does fine.
I mean this is a,
there's a like sort of a point of
diminishing returns when it comes to
lifting weights and then doing fine
motor skill activities.
Yeah,
he used to fuck with me drawing too.
If I lift a lot of ways my hands would
get tired from like gripping and
squeezing things and then when I would
draw like my fine motor skills with my
hands would be off.
It's true.
It does.
It affects it a lot.
Our team,
we had this team called the molly boys,
so that was my rectum.
Molly boys like they're all,
the boys were all on molly all met
hanging out doing molly and then we make
what an
athletic crew.
A lot of edits you very positive squad
closet and squat,
but he's hugging everybody.
Yeah,
it's okay.
Did he miss me a hug bro?
Go.
We lose by 30 it's cool bed.
I love the pockets.
Yeah,
we look like fucking clowns are jerseys
had like molly ringwald face on him and
it said,
mom,
there is,
please show me.
I want to put that shit on online.
You got to fucking join the squad.
Joe Donnelly,
boy's Jersey.
Amen.
Come on.
I think.
I think I might even have one in the
fucking backseat of my car.
[inaudible] boy's Jersey with your name
all over.
We need to have that.
You're going to after the show,
you got to give me that photo and I'm
going to put it on instagram.
Satisfies God damn hilarious.
Yo,
my boy Bernard designed this shit.
Molly boys.
Yes.
Here it is.
Look at these jerseys.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
What happened to her man?
I don't,
uh,
she's been in a couple films.
I saw her in something in the news
recently,
but not,
I don't know what happened,
man.
That's a weird world.
She peaked that peak,
Bro.
The eighties movie world is a weird
world.
I'm surprised that people sell in press
pills.
Haven't put her face on like oppress
pill yet.
That would,
that would sell like wildfire.
Anybody out there and making pressed
pills in your bathtub.
Monitoring Wells face on them.
I know,
right?
You would think that would be the one
people forgot about her.
People forgot about mt got about home.
You should sell those.
I forgot a lot of holes.
Yeah,
I,
you know what?
This is for the love.
I'm only giving them the friends like
you.
You get them in the trunk.
One left.
Oh my God.
What size you are spoken.
Swole.
He might be too for the chairs.
I'm hanging up on the wall,
man.
Dude,
I'll wear it.
I'll stretch it out.
Make it a Jamaica tank top.
Make it something.
My only word.
That gym.
I like it.
So you're doing that three times a week.
You're playing basketball.
That's dedication.
I would think to that alone.
All that activity.
That would be a great way to lose
weight.
Yeah.
My fitbit says I'm doing work.
It's great.
The fitbit in the scale.
Disagree though.
What's the food?
Definitely the food.
It's food.
My job.
But you make delicious shit.
How hard is it when you make delicious
shit to eat non delicious shit.
That's a problem because it's almost
like as like imagine for a guy like me
as a comic.
What if I was a comic,
but the only way to be healthy it was to
listen to shitty jokes.
Oh,
guts.
Kind of like what's going on because you
describe yourself as sandwich artist.
Ultimately what you are is uh,
an Ileus subway employee
full time.
It's,
well there's a lot of jared jokes.
No,
but I'm going to,
we're going to keep moving.
But you,
you're making delicious art,
you know,
and then
you're eating styrofoam,
you know?
Yes.
My problem also is I make fire,
I eat it,
but then later on at night,
even if,
if I'm not making,
I will eat anything you put anything
from,
I'm going to eat it.
So you're a late night dude.
Late night is where I really do the
damage and then the booze to the booze
is a problem.
But I've been drinking less,
drinking less,
just smoking weed,
you know,
I think I'm going to get there.
What next time I come in here,
the mill shredded boost,
Hattie.
Oh,
oh.
Where's the beach?
So if you,
if you just cut out carbs,
you can still eat delicious shit.
Like that's the beautiful thing about
like trying to get into a ketogenic
diet.
There's like delicious steaks you can
eat,
you can eat some sweet potatoes,
you can eat like slinky sweet potatoes.
Yeah,
just fiber,
but just don't eat too much.
The,
the whole idea is to take in as little
sugar as possible and have your body
start operating off of fats.
And what else is a good fiber to eat
besides sweet potato?
Like what do you do for your cravings?
That's what's killing me.
Discipline.
That's what I do.
Fuck this stuff is uh,
this,
this stuff is called [inaudible].
This is a,
these are x xed exogenous ketones.
These are all minerals in a minute.
Amino acids.
And I add these to water and what they
do is they put your body in a state of
ketosis pretty rapidly.
They've wait,
this can put you in Ketosis by itself.
So somebody was telling me this,
right?
They're like,
if you don't eat carbs,
that your body creates key totes and
then it starts to eat your fat.
And I was like,
can I just fucking do a line of fucking
Ketos though?
Like,
why can't you just put these fuckers in
your body and it starts attacking your
fat?
Um,
that's what this does.
Well,
what that does is keep,
those are exogenous ketones and ketones
is what your body burns off and it's not
burning off carbohydrates.
There's a couple of benefits to it and
I'm not a scientist and I'm not that
smart so I'm going to butcher this,
but essentially one of the biggest
benefits is that when you,
when your body's eating carbs all the
time,
your body feeds off carbs.
For me at least what I would do is I'd
have these big peaks and then these
crashes like I would eat and then after
I ate I was like a bear that got shot
with a tranquilizer dart or and seals,
bears or collar and Debbie May.
I just,
it would crash hard,
man hard and then also after I ate about
five hours later,
I'd be fucking starving where my body
had processed all the food and then I'd
hit this place like,
fuck,
I got to eat.
I don't get there anymore.
I don't get to there to that I got to
eat thing like I can go 10 12,
14 hours without eating and I'm fine.
I might be a little hungry,
but I feel good like I've worked out
after 16 hours of not eating and be
fine.
Like what I'll do is I'll go to bed
early at an early at nine and I'll work
out at noon with nothing.
Eat nothing in between that time and
work out at noon and be fine.
But what we sound like the girls I knew
in high school though,
I could go 16 hours without eating
frozen yogurt up.
Yo,
this is also time Al Bundys favorite
flavor,
natural orange.
I remember when he made,
if you eat an orange to taste anything
like this dog shit,
throw the fucking thing in the garbage
immediately.
The purpose of cogenic still.
If I did the Bundy and I made like a
Tang sandwich with the cogenic span.
Exactly.
Okay.
Yeah.
You don't want to do,
but I do love this stuff.
I put the stuff in,
um,
in water and I mix it up,
drink it all the time,
showing this gets a little sloppy.
This envelopes a little sloppy.
I need to come up with a good,
uh,
sort of a,
um,
like a funnel to get it in there.
But what I do is I just kind of shake it
in slow.
Yeah.
You're smart man.
You're doing a little one.
What I do is I make a little hole and I
just put that little hole over the water
bottle.
You probably should use an actual glass
of water and said,
oh,
this is,
this isn't enough water.
No,
it's fine.
It's good.
I mean it's just going to be real
strong.
But I'm just saying if you had a glass
and you could mix that bitch up solid
like this Joe Rogan glass here.
Plus I liked the idea.
You drinking in my face.
Yeah.
Drinking a Mug of my face.
So,
um,
how long have you been trying to do
this?
Be Healthy and uh,
30,
40 years.
It hasn't really worked.
You just got to write down that you
don't allow yourself to drink at night
or allow yourself to eat shitty food at
night.
If you could just do that.
Yeah,
I started keeping it out of the crib.
And then the good thing is,
you know how La really helps fat people
is there's no bodegas.
See in New York,
it's like you could just walk downstairs
and be fat,
eat anything you want.
That's true.
And I missed the day cause that was the
big thing.
But in la there are,
they've taken the Bodegas away.
Yeah.
New York City.
In New York City has a lot of weird
spots where you can just show up and
well in New York City has restaurants
that are open 24 hours a day that are
really good.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
Incredible.
He has a few,
but they're super ethnic.
Like you can go to Thai town and you can
get some off fucking at nighttime.
There's some fucking Badass Thai food
that's opened up in La.
If you,
uh,
take,
um,
Hollywood or sunset,
Hollywood,
if you take Hollywood down and keep
going east,
there's a,
so that is not orange.
It's what I'm saying.
Someone needs to go to jail for lying.
I will call that barn set.
You go out there.
Well Take Hollywood,
um,
east of,
of highland.
Keep going.
And on the right hand side,
maybe like four or five miles is like a
whole tie area that um,
you'll go through like these uh,
these,
these areas where it's maybe like 20 or
30 Thai restaurants in a row down there
and there's one place open.
I'll take you down
there man.
If you want to go.
I'm just one place that's open.
Late at night.
I used to go with my buddy rob.
Rob came in,
world kickboxing champion and um,
he took me down to that place after
training one night.
It's fantastic.
And it's open till like two,
three o'clock in the morning.
What's the name?
I don't remember the name of the place.
Cause it's like some funky name.
Yeah,
I've been going to Thai town to this
spot.
Stop.
Coffee shop is good,
but they're not 24 hours.
They're good though.
With Thai coffee is hilarious because I
mean just why don't you just shoot sugar
into my veins with a needle?
You know like Thai iced tea and Thai
iced coffee.
That stuff is insane.
They put sugar and condensed milk.
Yeah,
like one wasn't enough.
Yeah.
It's double sugared up.
It's so yummy.
Right?
When someone does the organic tie spot
or or whatever,
it's going to be sugar condensed milk
and the Gavi,
that's what they're going to do.
A Golf I supposed to be super bad for
you.
Oh yeah.
Well everybody thinks that a Gaba is
like,
it's all natural man.
It's a Gaba.
Gaba is really good.
A Gavi is apparently converted into your
body.
Just like sugar.
Like just like cane sugar.
If you don't know,
I never thought it could be too great
for you too though.
Cause it's like,
it looks like it's made from the same
thing they make Tequila from.
So I'm like right.
Kill bad for you.
It could be good.
It could be depends on who you're with.
A long term bet short term.
Incredible.
It's a trade off again,
it depends on the company you keep,
you know.
So this stuff exotic,
just ketones.
This is the way to go.
It's good to do a little pick me up in
between meals too.
I feel hot.
Hot,
like sexy.
Yeah.
Real fucking thing.
Like real skinny.
Yeah.
Real fucking hot boy over here.
The skinny look.
Yeah,
it's coming back.
Bringing it back.
Mine's mainly for basketball man.
But also I've been a human panda for a
while.
I'd like to be a human red panda.
They're a little more athletic and agile
and pandas and see them in trees and
shit.
They climb kind of jealous.
I'm like the fat fucking panda stuck to
the floor.
Do you have a trainer?
Yeah,
I do.
Really do.
I've been training with this.
This,
this dude Justin.
He's good.
Okay.
Yeah.
He started this gym called lip method.
It's been pretty good going.
What kind of Shit do you do?
Well,
as a isometrics,
plyometrics,
and then sometimes I'll do weights and
then I play ball.
So that's kind of like the four things I
do you ever fuck with kettle bells?
Yeah.
Kettle bells are good.
I do the Kettlebell swings and shit like
that,
and then step ups,
we kettlebells,
right?
Yeah.
I like kettle bells.
I feel like you got to get to a level of
buffing this for kettle bells,
but I do.
I know you can start with light ones.
Yeah.
The right way to do this is a
interesting podcasts that I've been
listening to with this guy,
Pavel,
tat saline.
He's,
I'm like,
sir,
the guy brought kettle bells to America
and he's on a Tim Ferriss,
his podcast,
I want to say number 55 or one 55 yeah,
I just found it last night.
If you'd told me about this back in this
catalog,
but trout around the 50 50 or 55 right?
Yeah.
He's to two podcasts in a row and he
talks
about like the correct way to do kettle
and the correct way to strength train,
and one of the things that he's saying
is you should never do more than five
repetitions.
You should like say if you can lift
something,
if you have a 100 pounds,
you can lift a hundred pounds nine
times.
You shouldn't do it nine times.
She should do it five due at five and
then put it down.
Don't,
don't go to failure.
And the idea is the body's not designed
to go to failure.
The idea is that going to failure all
the time.
You think like,
we have this idea in our head,
and I'm guilty of it more than anybody,
is that more is better.
You know,
I'm going to fucking work harder than
everybody else and that's just going to
do it.
Well,
that's not really the right way to do it
when it comes to the human body because
the,
even though your mind can push your body
to extreme limits,
oftentimes you get better results by not
pushing your body to extreme limits by
pushing your body intelligently,
allowing your by your body's sufficient
time to recover and then doing it again
and then doing it more often,
but with less repetitions.
So this is the thing I,
I've been joking around like,
oh,
lose weight is that,
it's true.
I want to do it for basketball.
But the thing I love about working out
and basketball is it teaches you shit
like this,
right?
Cause I think everything in the universe
has the same principles.
Do you know what I mean?
Like if you're cooking more is not
always better,
right?
If you're making music more is not
always better.
Right?
Like putting more things into a beat.
You need negative space,
right?
Things need space,
time to breathe and then so does the
human body.
And so I agree.
I don't do like exercises to fail.
I do them and my train is pretty good.
Like we'll go in and we'll do like 18
different exercises and we switch each
time.
It's not like sets of three and going
increasing in weight.
You've seen,
I'm sure you've seen this Jiro dreams of
Sushi.
Yeah.
Amazing.
Right?
Yeah.
One of the things that I love about that
is the simplicity of this guy's methods.
I mean that the,
if you haven't seen a documentary,
man,
I was so skeptical.
I'm like,
I'm not watching a fucking documentary
about due to make Sushi.
Like how fucking hard is it to make
Sushi?
Cut the fish,
shut the fuck up.
How hard is that?
It's hard as fuck.
It's hard as hell.
But the,
the methods of this guy,
employees like you would think,
well,
how hard is it to do?
Well,
it's not necessarily that it's hard,
but there's a right way to do it where
it's,
he's figured out like,
do you,
do you add this amount of this or that
amount of this?
Do you,
you know,
let it sit for six hours.
You let it sit for 12 hours and he's
nailed it and got it down to a science.
But if you did anything more than what
he's doing,
it would actually be less.
Yeah.
You know,
like a nice piece of seared.
I for example,
how hard is that?
It's not hard at all.
You get a fresh piece of I he,
you sear it,
but God damn when it's done right,
it tastes good.
Yeah.
Every culture is,
it's similar.
You go eat like the original food,
the traditional food authentic.
Like I went to Sicily,
it just read tuna,
Sicilian red tuna on a griddle,
the best restaurant I went to
insistently who's doing tuna on the
griddle low heat with olive oil and it
was just salt and it was the best piece
of two and I ever had.
Wow.
Yeah,
you'll see it's a,
we went to Piccola Napolli this episode
was good.
They're big on
seafood,
right?
Sicily's hugely is incredible on seafood
and they're very smart because they
don't add much to it.
They just use their olive oil.
That low heat sear,
real nice take the time is incredible.
Well I think that minimalism in a lot of
ways,
like even in music,
like a,
sometimes you listen to an acoustic
song,
just a dude in a guitar or a woman in a
guitar and it's the best song you've
ever heard.
Yeah.
For that moment.
I mean if there was one more piece of
fishing equipment on the shirt,
it fucking suck.
It'd be terrible.
There's just a net fishing equipment on
this shirt.
You love that shirt.
Do I do.
I do.
It all comes back.
It's all comes back to the shirt.
Tell me about your new vice show man.
What do you got going on?
It's been,
you know what this has been since I've
met you.
It's been in the works.
It almost,
I feel like it's a five year journey
really started this idea we and then we
went through it,
did it on the Internet,
you know,
eight minute clips,
10 minute clips and we did that for two
years and the last two years I haven't
had any episodes out because we've just
been grinding and we'd been in the lab
eight episodes and it took us eight
years and I have to give respect.
You know a lot of people look at say
other travel shows or Tony Bourdain and
you hear a lot of people pitch things
around town in New York.
Oh yeah.
This is like the new Tony Bourdain or
that's the Newtonian [inaudible].
You know what we got in the lab and we
made an hour long travel show.
It's a similar format and you know thing
that Tony is doing because he created
this format and I have to pay respect.
It's hard as fuck.
But what Tony did was he was the first
guy that ever had a cooking show that I
want to hang out with.
Yes.
And Tony is the first one that put a
narrative to a cooking show.
He gave it a narrative in a story and
character.
And so he created this format that a lot
of people have like followed in his
footsteps.
But I've always felt like,
you know,
when I started,
people are like,
oh no,
it's Tony or whatever.
And Tony was really helpful to me in my
career and he really supported me.
But I was like,
you know what?
My purpose in life wasn't to be another
version of my dad.
My Dad wanted me to work in a steak
house when I was a kid and just be like,
you own this restaurant after me and
we're going to sell steak.
That's what the wall is doing.
And I was like,
Dad,
I don't think that can be the point to
my life.
It can't be just to emulate you and be
like you.
And when it came to me doing this fight
stuff,
I've been for five years figuring out
how to get my voice and my story and the
things I care about.
The translate to tape and it looked,
it maybe looked a lot easier than I
thought it did.
But once you get to it and you start to
see what really makes these shows great,
you want to honor it,
you want to respect it and you want to
work hard.
So we took two years to make these eight
episodes.
Wow.
That's a long ass time.
And you know,
I think,
you know,
when you're trying to create a
television show,
it takes a while for a show to find its
legs,
right.
To figure out what it is.
Yeah.
With anything,
even with the city column or a talk
show,
you know,
I mean,
uh,
I was there for the early days that
Conan O'brien show.
One of my buddies was one of the writers
and I got to see them do it and it's,
it was,
I was,
I remember being there going,
wow,
it's going to be interesting to see how
this works out because this is obviously
lot on Bambi legs right now.
Like it's like,
like a fawn.
Yeah.
My thing was I always had the vision and
I knew what I wanted to do,
so that was part one.
Then the last few years have been
actually doing it and then once you do
it,
the hardest part in this town is
convincing other people that they should
put it out.
You know,
because other people look at it and
they're like,
oh well it's not like,
it's not like Tony and it's not like the
show,
like what is this?
And I'm like just,
it's different.
And that's the point because I didn't
want to go make a show that's like
anybody else's.
It may be the same time format and you
say 44 minute travel show,
structured,
unstructured reality,
whatever.
But I was like,
this is a new thing.
But it took me a long time to get the
vision,
create it,
and then get people to believe in it.
You know,
getting people to believe in your shit
is I think the hardest.
That third step is the hardest part.
Well who did you need to get to believe
it because you're doing it on advice,
right?
Yeah.
Shane already believes in you and Shane.
Shane is the one that gives me the
freedom.
Shane,
Eddie Murray,
they're the ones that let me do it,
you know,
but they're not there every day.
So this is a show runner and there's a
producer and then all these people,
cause we out in Fukushima shooting
radioactive wolves and shit.
Mother Fucker,
he's the man.
I saw him last night,
Shane's the man and he,
he always gives me the freedom,
but it's,
it's even the people on your crew
getting everybody to buy in and believe.
And we came back with the footage and
these things,
it gets into post and then everybody who
gets to watch an and post has an opinion
about what this show should be.
And I just,
I fought and fought and fought all eight
of these episodes.
Finally we're going to put them out and
all eight of them are exactly how I feel
about the places I visited and the
people we met.
And my biggest struggle was travel
shows.
They voiceover a lot.
There's a lot of voiceover and it's
almost like these shows are written
before people go to these towns and
these cities and what the people say.
Sometimes it doesn't matter because the
producer,
whoever's going has already decided the
story wants to tell.
I go out there and we booked the scenes
and the thing that made everybody
nervous and pre preproduction was I was
like,
I don't know what these people are going
to say and we're going to live with the
footage.
And they're like,
no,
you have to have an idea.
You have to like direct the
conversation.
We need a write voiceover and we need to
set it up.
And I was like,
let's just go to these towns,
meet these people and let them tell us
about their lives,
their cities,
their identities and except the footage.
And I think being honest,
accepting footage,
not manipulating the footage with a ton
of voiceover is the real innovation of
our show.
It's verite.
You see us making the show,
so it's never like you're not aware of,
we're making a show.
You see what is the,
what is the premise of the show?
I'm exploring and deconstructing
identities through what people eat does.
You're basically like going through
their shit.
Like,
what's in your poop?
You know what I mean?
Fucking red tuna,
olive oil,
you know?
But I'm going through these countries
and exploring their history and identity
just through what they eat.
Because what you eat tells you so much
about who you are,
your culture,
your values,
your politics,
and your history and what has happened
to your ancestors.
Like where'd you go?
Cecily?
Istanbul.
Yeah.
Hunan.
China.
Sand.
Don't China.
Taiwan.
Orlando Juarez.
Mexicali.
You went to Warren?
Yeah.
Went to Juarez.
It was great puzzle.
Very credible.
It's not scary.
You know,
I don't,
I never would oversell it until you,
those fucking just fucking scary out
there.
I mean,
look,
everyone there had a story of somebody
in their family being killed or
kidnapped or robbed is bad and you know,
it's bad.
But when we went out there,
I cannot claim that it was hard or rough
for us.
We rode bikes through the city and
there's a lot of these kids out there
doing things trying to take back wall
brass.
So you may look at like a bike ride
through your town here.
I was like some hipster,
weird yuppy thing,
but in Juarez they were like,
we even,
we would just love the right to be
yuppies.
Do you know I have the freedom to be
yuppies and this time we can't even ride
our bikes without a problem here.
So we rode bikes with like 50,
60 kids.
And while that's just kind of civil
disobedience,
trying to take back the streets by
riding through them.
So it was it,
when you say they would like to be able
to ride bikes,
like it's just because of the drug
violence.
They does a lot of islands.
There's a lot of violence.
People are afraid to go outside.
And,
um,
this is one of the symbolic things that
the youth out there do if they try to
take back the city and the town by
riding through it with bikes.
Got Butter coffees.
Got You.
Huh?
Keep another coffee is killing me.
But it's great.
I mean,
so like what kind of food?
Obviously Mexican food,
but like what kind of food we were
getting in wars.
The best food I had was outside the
nightclubs.
There was this one little Taco stand in
Juarez on the main strip that,
you know,
the rolling stones,
whoever used to go perform at the main
venue in Juarez after the show there was
this small taco spot.
All they do is like El Pastore.
You go over there and that was the best
Taco I've ever had.
What does that stand for?
I'll pet store.
What does it mean?
It's uh,
the pastor?
No,
I don't know.
I just know you get pineapples and it's
grilled pork and it's on a spit and it's
incredible.
My thing is usually Tang,
I like language.
I like beef tongue tacos.
But that Al Pastore Taco was the best I
had.
Wow.
And the rolling stones used to go there.
Yeah,
after the shows and stuff like that.
How long ago were they going to Juarez?
Mexico.
It's like in the seventies seventies
yeah.
Yeah.
And El Paso,
they would do the shows and El Paso and
then cross over and shit like that.
Really?
Yeah.
So do shows in El Paso and then go to
Mexico for food and then they also did
them.
I believe I have to,
I have to catch myself.
I have to check the tape.
I can't remember if
it's,
they did the shows and I'll pass when
went to Juarez,
the party after or it's,
they did the show in Juarez and went to
the Taco stand because they did have a
venue next door to this thing.
So I think at some bands did.
El Paso came over,
some bands did the venue next to the
Taco spot and went over.
But it was a combination.
It's crazy.
Rolling Stone was,
I can't remember if they were El Paso or
warmers,
but there were tons of bands in that
triangle going back and forth between
the border and people would come across
the board at a party in Juarez and it
was a thing.
It was no big deal back then.
That's what's crazy is that when I was a
kid,
you never heard about violence in Mexico
piece should go to Mexico to party.
Everybody go to Aqua Poco to go to
Tijuana.
It was just fun.
I mean,
it was crazy.
You know,
they would all talk about donkey shows
and all the crazy shit that you'd go
over there and see.
But it was never like,
don't go to Tijuana because of drug
violence.
Yeah.
That all happened during the Bush
administration.
Yup.
I went to,
um,
uh,
Cancun and like a 2002 or something like
that for mtv and MTV did a spring break
thing down there.
And Man,
it was,
it was fun.
It was great.
And then within seven or eight years,
nobody would go.
Yeah,
I mean,
within seven or eight years,
everybody was terrified.
And going to Mexico,
all you heard in the news,
and I'm sure a lot of it was exaggerated
and um,
I mean,
if it bleeds,
it leads,
right?
If the news is going to show you some
shit about Mexico,
it's not going to show you al Pastore
Tacos and how great it is on the street.
The murders are real.
But then the thing is,
is that we have to remember in all these
towns,
you see these murders,
you see the gang violence,
there's real people living through that
shit.
There's real people trying to live
normal lives.
And that's why we did this episode on
the border towns in Mexico.
We went to Tijuana,
Mexicali and Juarez,
and we tried to show the lives that
these people are trying to live next to
a superpower because just by the sheer
nature and geography of them living on
the border next to a superpower,
of course crime is going to leak into
their towns.
The dirts going to be done on their
side.
The product's going to be sent to our
side,
you know?
And so we tried to capture their lives.
And so that's an example of one episode
of the show.
Well,
the other problem is they're like sort
of see their economies completely
connected to the United States and a lot
of ways where it's like there's plenty
of violence in America that we don't
even consider.
Like nobody's scared to go to Chicago,
but Chicago is fucked up,
man.
There's more gun violence in Chicago
than almost anywhere in North America in
Chicago is terrible right now.
It's,
it's definitely an American life.
It's the most murders in any cities.
It's cool.
It's right up there.
I think it's Chicago and Detroit,
but no one's like,
oh my God,
we can't go to Chicago on the South
Chicago,
you know,
hey,
let's go to Chicago.
It's,
we don't even consider it.
Yeah,
it's all in the south side.
But I mean that's sort of the same way
people have to look at about Mexico.
But I'll do,
I do have tie this one story.
I went to this resort recently in Mexico
near Puerto Vallarta and I was like,
wow,
this place is so pretty.
Like,
how is it that Mexico has all this drug
violence and all these problems,
but uh,
this,
this beautiful resort
and all these a wealthy people go to
vacation,
this resort and they had these little
golf carts that they give you on the
resort to move around the resort.
And we took the golf cart and they'll
like,
you can go into the city if you like,
you know,
you could take the golf carts anywhere
you want.
It's like,
all right,
let's go into the city.
So we go into the city and we went a
block from that resort one block and we
found a fucking small military based
with armored vehicles with dude sitting
on their,
on machine guns with steel plates in
front of them,
ready to rock at a moment's notice.
So that's how they keep these wealthy
people like protected.
I was like,
wow,
this is a wake up call right here.
And that's the thing that like,
our leaders never do a good job of that
violence in the south side of Chicago.
That should affect all Americans,
but it doesn't.
And until it affects somebody who
doesn't live in the south side and the
murder accidentally bleeds into the
wrong neighborhood on the north side,
nobody really cares.
Nobody pays attention.
And that's why we went to Mexico too,
because there's this border that is a
false border.
Like Mother Nature didn't put a board in
there.
We put a fucking pillow.
No.
Gotcha.
That border Sun,
God made the border between United
States and Mexico.
God made it that way.
God has a plan.
Exactly.
We are the chosen people.
And so I just wanted to show like,
hey man,
on the other side of this artificial
line,
this is what's going on.
And just because there are different
color than you are,
it's a different country.
It doesn't mean you shouldn't care about
this.
Like this is a human problem.
Well people are so terrified of opening
up the bores in Mexico and letting
people go back and forth there.
They're so terrified of the idea.
But how many Mexicans are already over
here illegally and doesn't seem to be
that much of a problem.
And I mean there's plenty of natural
born Americans that are fucking things
up just as bad as anybody else.
And most of the Mexicans I know are
hardworking people that are very
friendly.
Like if you go to Mexico,
one of the things you find like right
away is how friendly people are.
Mexican is a nice place,
incredible place.
Nice.
I never felt threatened or anything.
And the thing is is that the world needs
more transparency and mobility,
right?
The,
the thing that I noticed for two years
traveling around the globe,
going to all these places,
Mediterranean,
Sicily where there's immigration issues
is Stan Bull,
you know,
Mexico on the borders.
We need transparency because the Po,
the leaders of this world are drawing
lines all around creating divisions that
are not there between me and you or
Jamie or people in the in Mexico that I
met.
You know,
and we need to have mobility because it
can't just be my dumb luck that I was
born in America and then I'm going to
have a better life because my mom pop
the squad here.
Right.
You know,
it's sad.
Like I go around the world,
I'm like,
man,
if that person was born here,
they'll probably be doing a better job
than me.
What I'm doing.
Well it's eroding.
It's eroding slowly but not,
not quick enough.
Not Clicking.
No.
What,
what used to be a necessity,
like we had to keep our tribe away from
invading tribes because we couldn't
communicate with them.
We didn't know their language.
People came from some other land to try
to take our,
we had a protect
it.
They would come over and boats and
they'd rape and pillage.
That's not really the case anymore.
So there's necessity of having these
borders and,
and,
and especially in 2016 having it where
you can't go back and forth,
you can't even cross into lands,
lets you have the right papers and he
definitely can't work here because you'd
be taking
jobs.
Yeah.
Taken our jobs.
There's plenty in the world man,
like people and,
and the what,
the 1% got to get better at sharing too,
you know,
cause there's people in the world that
just sit on piles of shit and it's not
in the economy.
It's quite an ecosystem,
Dave.
And there's,
there's Middle Eastern.
That's Chinese too.
Did a lot of Chinese people sitting on
piles of shit that's not moving well,
that's,
yeah,
we'll stockpiling wealth is a weird
thing,
right?
When people get to this point where
they're just constantly,
well,
if you have like billions and billions
of dollars,
but yet you're still involved in
constantly trying to accumulate wealth,
that's a little weird too.
I wanted to run this idea by you please.
I listen to his show and I love the idea
as you bring up,
I'm convinced and I wished there was a
politician that was,
that was promoting this,
but I think there should be a salary cap
on the world.
A salary,
salary cap,
because you put it in sports and it
works.
Right?
But think about it.
Do you,
would you ever need more than $500
million?
Me?
Yeah.
Plans to come on.
I need islands.
Shit.
Rocket ships.
I want to go to the moon.
I feel like you could go to the moon for
under 500 Mil.
I guarantee you can't,
isn't there that one dude,
the backstreet boy,
uh,
Lance Bass,
he's going to go to the moon on a big
Dick.
Come on.
But okay,
so you,
you would need more than 500 mil.
I don't know.
No,
no,
not in real life.
No,
not if I'm being serious.
But here's how much money would get put
back into the market and like would be
distributed.
If you just set a salary cap at 500 Mil,
well that would break up so much money.
It's interesting,
but someone who makes more than $500
million could take that money and
started gigantic business and hire
hundreds of millions of people.
I mean,
just because,
do you have a hundred?
You just promote reaganomics bro.
Trickle down economics is real.
Just like God had us born here in
America.
God also made it so
you don't have a salary cap.
Um,
it,
it's interesting,
but if you play monopoly and which is,
that's what everybody's doing,
right?
Everybody's,
there's plenty money.
What's a game?
I mean there's the gay capitalism in a
lot of ways.
A lot like a game you're trying to
accumulate and some people are more
dedicated to that game and they try to
accumulate constantly.
I mean if I was more dedicated to just
doing the things that I do,
if I was more dedicated in a capitalist
sense,
I would accumulate more money.
But my personal belief is that would
fuck with me creatively because it would
take away resources that I use for other
things.
It would fuck with the way I do the
podcast.
If you,
if you only think about how much money
you can make,
there's certain things you wouldn't say.
There's certain ways you wouldn't speak.
And the ironic irony in my that would
ultimately cost me money cause my
product would suffer.
So I think in a lot of ways the game of
capitalism itself,
just calling it a game,
um,
it you,
it's very problematic if you have a cap
on how much money you can make in that
game because there's always going to be
these outliers.
He's Michael Jordans of sport that take
things to the fucking end fill level and
go deep and want to make as much money
as they possibly can and I don't
necessarily think that that's bad.
I think you should have the freedom to
be fucking crazy.
You should have the freedom.
If you want to make,
you want to be the first guy that makes
$100 billion,
you should have the freedom to do that,
but as a human being who makes that much
money,
you also should have a,
an understanding of what kind of an
impact you can have on other people with
that money from your own personal
perspective,
you can take that money and invest it in
different communities.
You can start programs,
you could give people scholarships.
You could do all this amazing stuff with
that money that you wouldn't be able to
do if somebody put a cap and said,
you can only make 500 million bucks,
but here's the way I see money,
right?
Money is something we've created.
Money is,
is a man made creation.
This idea of money is to attach value to
things.
That's what money is.
So the game isn't making money.
Money's like an award.
So it's like if a movie director was
like,
yes,
I make movies to win Oscars,
that's not what the game is.
It should be to make a great film,
right?
You should be to live a good life and we
reward you along the way because if you
do things that are of value to a
society,
we pay you,
right?
You know?
But the game is,
the game is basketball.
The game is football.
The game,
his movies to game is podcasting or
truth telling.
It's not making money.
And that's where I think human beings
and society have lost their way because
now it's just about winning the award.
It's not about doing the work.
And if,
where's that money
go though?
Here's the problem.
I was saying,
if you say Eddie Wong could only make
$500 million a year,
but all of a sudden your Bolan and you
hit that ceiling tank,
tank,
you're just slamming up against that
ceiling and every year and you're like,
you know what,
man,
I would have made $3 billion this year,
but I only made 500 million because
there's a fucking cap on this bitch.
I could have taken that money.
I could invest it in communities.
I could've started all these,
these centers for a young kids and helps
them out.
People I know and you if,
let's say you had 500 Mil,
you couldn't make any more.
I bet you'd still do this podcast.
I bet you'd still be working out.
You'd still be telling jokes.
I'm still living on a mountain.
No,
about the government.
Where's the rest of my fucking money?
And you'd be taping it,
but what would you do with the rest of
the money?
How's it work?
Say like save you made $3 billion one
year,
but the cap was at 500 million,
so they just cut you off and all the
rest of that money goes where.
Yeah,
you just,
your idea sucks.
Come on.
No fucking idea.
I have a few.
I have a few government.
It wouldn't be the rubber for wealth
now.
I think that you have to then find a way
to distribute it through nonprofits and
things like that.
Right.
Cross,
we're like 80% of the money goes to
bullshit.
Yeah.
It doesn't even go to the actual,
we would have to build a better
infrastructure.
We would have to build a better
infrastructure for social services and
public interests and things like that
because yes,
the nonprofit sector,
a lot of the times it's super
ineffective at remedying the issues that
everybody's giving them money for.
Problem is that there's so much money
involved in red tape and bullshit and
employees and overhead and all the
different operating costs.
When you look at the actual operating
cost involved in charities and you
compare it to how much money actually
goes to the charity that you're sending
money to.
It's disturbing and it makes people feel
sad.
Well,
I'll tell you this like I just think
that we have to reconfigure our,
our values and how we value things and
like we're stuck on this money thing
like the human species is.
So we're stuck on money.
Well I think we're stuck on money
because a lot of people don't have it.
So it's the ultimate thing.
Some people have too much of it.
Some people do.
Like when you don't have money,
like when I was young and I didn't have
any money,
man,
I remember the first check that I got,
I got a big check from Disney.
I've got a development deal when I was
like 24 and all of a sudden I didn't
have to worry about my bills.
It was the first time in my life I
didn't have to worry about my bills and
I was like,
my rent is taken care of this month.
I can go out to eat.
And I remember it was like a physical
feeling of like,
like a physical feeling of relaxation.
Like now all of a sudden the,
the overhead cloud of debt and worry
about my bills had lifted and the sun
was shining and I was like,
oh,
and I will never forget that feeling.
So does that feeling was a revelation as
far as like how much stress I was under
and most people are under on a daily
basis.
So because of that stress,
what people think about is,
man,
I got to make money because that is the
way to get away from this fucking
stress.
Yes.
Because it becomes this carrot that if
we ever get to eat,
yeah,
money angling carry,
you know,
money gives you freedom.
And my brother emory's idea with the
salary cap things,
he's a bit of a futurist.
He's like,
Yo,
I read a lot of these things.
Robots can do a lot of our agriculture
in the future.
We can have a lot of our processes that
require human beings to clock in and
clock out and punch buttons to like go
to robots in the future.
Oh,
I see.
What you're trying to do.
You're trying to get rid of the American
farmer.
Okay,
so he says this,
he says this,
right?
And he was like,
some people want to play the game.
Eddie,
he's like you,
you wake up everyday,
you want to write,
you want to go do something,
you want to be productive.
He's like,
some people,
they just want to live.
And so after the salary cap,
after 500 million,
what of that money from those
billionaires and one percenters goes
into,
uh,
guaranteeing a baseline amount of
wealth.
Maybe it's $30,000,
and it goes to American people who are
not making that much money.
And it's like,
here's 30,000.
Here's your bills taken care of.
Here's an apartment.
Now you have no excuse.
You have no excuse.
Go do something you care about.
Go do something you love,
contribute back to society because this,
the disguise making
is going to guarantee you baseline
amount of living if you really do,
like,
if you really do like reading youtube
comments,
read the comments on how retarded that
ideas,
because people are fucking lazy and they
don't give people guaranteed money.
They're not going to do shit.
They're gonna Jack off into the street.
They're going to take shits on the cars
as they pass by.
They're going to do whatever.
They're lazy.
They're doing it anyway.
But you remove the incentive to work.
Like if you give people your,
you're going to create a welfare world.
But if you have robots,
right?
If you have robots doing this stuff
right,
this is my brother's thing and I'll
fight for his or idea.
If you have,
if you have robots that can do
agriculture,
and it's true,
there's machines everywhere.
They're doing things that humans used to
do.
In the future,
we will have machines that can do a lot
of the processes that humans do,
and it's like,
why continue to penalize people who just
aren't,
they don't have the drive and they don't
want to do things analyzing them.
They have to pull their own weight.
Like the whole reason why there's an
incentive to work.
Yeah.
It's because if you work you a thing and
you don't just survive,
you earn something and you get to
understand that effort.
Kidney reward.
Now people don't have effort equals
reward.
The government just gives you a reward.
Then it becomes,
how come I only took 30,000 I could
barely get born on 30,000 when Bill
[inaudible] Camaro.
But then you're looking at the worst of
the worst.
You'll,
there's a lot of people know that
nature,
man.
If you take people from scratch and give
and make them entitled from scratch and
just have them programmed to think that
money comes free and it's coming off,
and then you have a nation of spoiled
kids,
you ever seen a spoiled rich parents?
I,
they want you to spoil all.
Let me ask you this.
Motivational.
Do you think you can change people?
You definitely could change them.
If you give him $30,000 a year,
you can make them lazy.
You can.
You make people lazy and they didn't
earn that money,
then you can't just give people money
for no reason.
That and help people contributes.
It doesn't make a better society.
I just wanted to make your baseline
people shelter,
clothing,
food,
health services.
I just want to thin the herd.
Okay?
I want wolves in the streets.
I want to make it harder.
I want end to that.
I want people to get into that.
To live in the woods for a month out of
the year.
Yeah.
I've just worked with some people where
men,
there's these people who work super hard
and we can't pay them enough.
It's not in the budget.
There's not the opportunity,
and I'm like,
man,
I wish I could do more for this guy.
Then there's Pete.
What do you mean?
Like what people,
this is a very utopic guys that work on
the show would make.
There's guys and girls that work on the
show.
APS thinks like that and I'm like,
man,
you know what?
I wish we could pay him more because I
think you're doing great work,
but the economics of this project and
this show,
this is what it is.
Then I have people who've I've worked
with on other shows where they just
don't show up.
They don't show up.
They don't work hard.
They're just clocking in,
clocking out,
and they don't care.
Right,
but then I was like,
that never change that dial.
Never.
I will never change that guy.
They might,
but they would have to have sort of a
life affirming
experience.
Like something would have to happen in
near death experience.
I'll losing a loved one,
a revelation,
a psychedelic drug experience,
but some of his fights,
my biggest,
my biggest failures in life,
Joe,
is me trying to inspire or give
motivation to someone who just does not
care.
Yeah,
you can't do that.
And that's,
if you give people $30,000 a year,
that's what you're gonna get to be a
problem.
People need insulin check off somewhere
bad.
They need an incentive.
They need,
they need something to get them to work.
And then in doing that,
you create people that understand and
value hard work and discipline.
And it's not just about making money.
It's also about understanding yourself
and knowing that you can accomplish
things and not just accomplish things
from a financial standpoint,
but accomplish things as far as like
going on a diet and taking care of your
health,
pursuing an athletic goal,
pursuing a creative goal of like
finishing a book or writing a manuscript
or,
well,
there's,
there's a lot of things that people
won't do if you just give them money.
I agree.
I've,
I've met a lot of crappy entitled people
who they,
they don't give an effort because they
don't have to.
There are a lot of those people,
but then I meet a lot of people who they
just don't have their baseline needs and
there's a part of me that's like,
man,
I wish I could guarantee baseline needs
for these people because even if they
wanted to work,
there isn't an opportunity for them.
Right,
but your baseline needs all right.
In this country,
if w if you look at like the amount of
people in this country that have
baseline need issues and how much money
they earn as opposed to the rest of the
world.
You know,
this is a crazy statistic that I've
quoted before.
If you make more than $34,000 a year,
you are in the 1% of the world,
the world,
the planet earth.
But living in America,
you make $30,000 there's some people,
men like they can't even pay parking
tickets and they ended up in jail and
they have jobs and they work and it's
fucking hard.
Parking tickets get you in jail.
Really get there's,
there's a few cases,
not,
not a few.
There's tons of cases where you don't
pay your parking tickets.
They pull you over again late parking
tickets.
They'll end up putting you in jail.
Like there was a case,
I think it was in,
I think there was a couple of cases in
Ferguson,
Missouri that people were talking about
last year with,
with a woman,
a couple of people who did not have the
money to pay their parking tickets or
traffic violations and that over time
you can't pay,
you end up in jail.
Well,
it's a cycle that's kind of crazy.
And then this is definitely not have to
look at Jamie,
let's not.
But if it can definitely,
I mean definitely do better than put
people in jail for not I parking tickets
are fucking ridiculous.
First of all.
I mean if there's a violation as far as
like some on parking in front of a fire
hydrant or something like that,
that makes sense to me.
Or parking in front of a driveway,
like that kind of shit.
But the idea of charging,
hey,
but the idea that you're charging people
to park on the street,
it's fucking gross anyway that you have
a meter and I have to put money in his
meter so I could park my car.
I bought,
fuck you.
You know,
these are p,
these are streets that were paying for
with our taxes.
By the way,
this is a public street.
And the idea that you're going to just
steal money from people because they
have to park somewhere.
Yeah,
it's gross.
And not only that,
you have this fucking asshole and a bus
or there's little scooter thing that
goes around and gives tickets.
Then march your tire would chalk to make
sure that you're,
you know,
you've,
you've not been parking there for
northern 90 minutes.
I'll give you a ticket for that too.
It's all gross man.
Oh that shit's gross.
Either way.
Next time I come on India,
have more fully fleshed out salary cap
idea.
But I'm telling you like,
I've been thinking about this thing that
do it.
I mean there's,
there's gotta be ways that are better
than that.
And the big way is my feeling if,
I mean,
I've discussed this before,
but my feeling that this country has a
lot of places where you're like
Baltimore.
I had Michael Wood on,
on the podcast before.
He's a former police officer from
Baltimore who talked about how crazy it
is there and how they would find when he
was a cop.
They found this manifest from like the
1970s it was a directive of like a how
to engage in different areas and where
the crime is and where the drug
violences and where the breaking room
and he's like,
this was the same shit that we were
dealing with in the two thousands he's
like,
is this same areas the same problems?
The same exact like this is where the
drugs are,
this is what the crime is.
It was the same thing.
He's like,
no one fixed it and when you're stuck in
that kind of a cycle,
that is where the government should be
sending money.
Where's always setting money?
These countries sending money to
Afghanistan and Iraq and trying to
rebuild nations.
How about rebuild this fucking nation?
Yeah.
How about these problems that we have?
If we want this country to be stronger,
the best way to make a stronger country
is to have less losers.
All right.
Now when you get a shitty hand,
if you have two ones,
but you have four aces,
what the fuck man come one.
Well,
we had to figure out a way.
We have to figure out a way to make the
hands that people are dealt with in life
far easier to move with.
Yes.
And there's a lot of people that are
dealt with a fucking terrible shitty
hand and we just turn a blind eye
towards these terrible impoverished
communities that are fucking filled with
crime.
And these children that grow up there,
by the time they get to be 17 and 18
they've seen so much shit and the
program programming in their mind is so,
so disturbing because everything that
they've been involved with,
everything they've seen,
they've seen loved ones getting
carceration.
They seen people get shot,
they've seen crime,
they've seen a lack of hope.
They've seen police brutality,
they seen all these terrible things.
That is what we need to clean up in this
country.
Not Ski people from making tons of
money.
Well,
the thing is,
all right,
if I take the salary cap thing of when,
my idea is this though is I want to
guarantee a baseline of living for
people in America.
So it's like there,
but they have to work for that.
So you don't even know what you,
if someone doesn't let us,
somebody just wants to sit there.
Food,
mood Joe.
I know a lot of people that want to work
and they can't get jobs.
Well that's a different story.
Also,
if you're born in some of those
communities,
the key word you said is hope.
A lot of kids don't have hope.
I remember a kid that I used to hustle
with.
This is a good guy.
Yeah.
We,
we,
we sold shit outside the cake shop,
whatever,
right.
Weed.
I was selling weed,
whatever.
It's not a big deal.
Whatever.
Weed,
Xanax,
sound silly things.
All right.
And then,
uh,
he also was like a a night manager at
target.
Right?
And he's a night manager at target.
It's kind of wasting away.
He was like 1920 years old.
Incredible basketball player.
One of the best a IU basketball players.
I've seen and he got offers to play at
some jucos and things like that.
And I remember one day we went up to
Harlem to get the work and I was coming
back down on the train.
I was like,
Fam,
you should sign up.
You should go to that Juco.
You should enroll.
Like right now it's July,
there's still time you enroll now.
You could be in there for the fall
semester and you could play ball.
You're 19 years old to this man.
And I remember we just passed the stop
and he's like,
Nah man,
it'll never happen.
I'm like,
why?
And he's like,
you don't get it Eddie.
Like the way you are your parents,
like Dave taught you,
you have a chance.
I don't have a chance.
He's like,
I've been told my whole life,
I don't have a chance.
You know,
I live with my grandmother and whether
he's right or not,
I disagree with him.
He does have a chance.
But he had psychologically been broken,
had no hope,
and did not believe he could do
anything.
And when I saw that,
it fundamentally changed me because it
was like,
Ma,
I'm privileged.
I'm privileged because my parents,
maybe they beat the crap Outta me.
Maybe they were hard on me,
but I never,
I never didn't feel like I had a chance
if I worked hard.
Right.
There's a lot of people in this world
that just for 20 years they've lived in
America and they like,
even if I worked hard,
even I see my parents working hard.
We just never got the opportunity.
Right.
There's thousands and thousands and
thousands of stories of people who grew
up in similar environments that didn't
have that mindset that even though they
were told they didn't have any hope,
they said,
I'll show you,
and they went out and they made,
made their shit happen and they became
rich and successful.
Yeah.
That guy could have been that.
He chose to feel sorry for himself.
You were telling him some good things.
You were giving him some good advice.
He didn't want to listen and he didn't
want to listen.
And he was telling you is consciously
aware that he had been programmed to
think there was no hope,
if that's what he was telling you,
that's on him,
man.
And there's always going to be that.
And that is an example for you because
the people that fail on this weird
fucking race that we're all in or this
weird experience that were on when they,
when they fail,
if you can't help them,
at least you can learn from them.
You know?
And we can look along the way a
different people that have done terrible
things and we could say,
well,
what they did was awful and they should
be punished.
And that is almost definitely true.
But also we can learn that this could
happen to anybody who's in the wrong
circumstances,
had the wrong mindset and chooses the
wrong actions.
These,
all these things are important.
These are,
these are important,
not just for the person that's involved
in that situation,
but for everyone else observing because
we learn from each other.
We don't just learn by experience.
We learn from other people's experiences
and it's very,
very important that way because we can
experience other people's lives just to,
through sheer communication as one of
the most beautiful things about social
media is that we can all share much more
information than has ever been possible
before.
And through that you can learn,
hey,
you know who else was told that he would
never amount to be shit?
Jay Z,
you know,
you know who else grew up in a shitty
neighborhood,
you know this fucking basketball player
or that MMA fighter or this standup
comedian or that artist.
There's a million examples of people who
will turn,
we'll told they're not going to be shit.
Yeah,
but you are an exceptional dude in some
of the guys you mentioned,
they're exceptional dudes.
Might I?
I agree with every word you said.
You are saying everything my parents
ever said to me and I listened and I
fucking did the war.
My parents told me get a job.
That's what my parents did.
They told me I wasn't funny.
They told me fighting is dangerous.
They told me all the wrong things.
Yeah.
My mom's still told the way a few months
ago that I should still open a law firm.
She's like,
yeah,
what's you're doing is funny.
It's cool.
It's okay,
but you should do something solid that
you can count on it.
That's hilarious.
My mom still does not separate voyeurs.
They die of being tired and just
unhappy,
misery,
exhausted and they just get coke and
hookers and shoot themselves.
Can I go to the bathroom?
Go to the bathroom.
It's a good time.
Just something has hit the Internet that
I don't know.
You need to show you.
I guess it may or may not be legit,
but then decided to retire young thanks
to the cheese catches later.
Conor mcgregor and he's trolling you
think so.
Fuck yeah.
There's a lot of people have been
hitting me up telling me to show you and
yeah,
no one knows what's going on.
I decided to retire young,
which means like 34 eventually,
not today.
[inaudible] man.
Unless he got fucking head kick today
and knocked into oblivion.
The idea that he's going to go out on a
loss like that to nate Diaz Hook.
He's got plenty of cash.
If he wanted to retire young and step
away,
I mean I guarantee you he probably made
somewhere in the neighborhood of 5
million bucks with Josie Aldo fight.
He probably made more than that for the
Nate Diaz fight.
I would,
I would imagine after he spent a fuck
load of Ed,
he's probably still got a few million
bucks laying around.
He's a hero in Ireland.
He could always make money.
You can always run a gym and be fine,
but if I had to guess,
it doesn't make any sense.
The only reason why it would make sense,
the only reason why it would make sense
as connor had actually thought about
retiring from mma before he got the call
for the UFC.
There was a point in time where he had
some friends that were experiencing some
serious health issues from fighting and
then most recently that young man from
the Portuguese guy died in an mma
contest,
which I think took place in the UK,
wasn't
I know what he involved or related in
some way to one of those guys that just
died too.
Didn't he know him or train with?
I think he trained with the,
the Portuguese guy that just died
recently.
It is entirely possible in that sense,
but if I had to guess,
there's no way he'd do it like this.
Yeah.
It also,
I was talking with someone as this was
going on,
might not,
doesn't even seem like he usually talks
on
twitter sorta like I might,
he could have gotten hacked maybe,
but we don't,
no one really knows what's going on
right now.
That's it.
That's if you've got hacked and that's
it.
That's all they're gonna do.
Yeah.
No,
I mean it hasn't been deleted yet and no
one else has really commented on it.
I would call bullshit,
but you never know.
I just highly doubted.
Stay tuned folks.
I think he's trolling.
If I had to guess,
I'd say he's trolling fucking around
people.
If he decided I'm going to retire young.
And then like I said,
like one day or two days later,
which means around 34 you know,
and he's like 28 now.
I mean,
he's smart.
He will retire young.
It's just there's some dudes stay in it
way too long.
They wind up with rattled domes.
She got to get out.
I feel,
I feel slim from this.
Cogenic is already.
Do you feel better?
It felt good.
Checked out,
checked out the keg in the bathroom was
good.
It's like a pony keg now what do you
try?
Do you have a target weight you're
trying to get to or a body fat number?
Yeah,
I want it.
I want to get to like 15 16% body fat 22
right now.
2123 so you don't have lofty goals.
You have reasonable goals.
Reasonable goals.
I'm not trying to be like shredded and
shit.
Why not?
I don't know.
I kind of liked being a dancing bear.
Do you like it or is it like your 19
year old friend that was like,
you don't understand.
There's no hope for me now.
I can never get shredded.
I just need,
I just need to be a little bit better at
basketball.
That's it.
That's don't want to be shredded.
Like if somebody gives you a pill,
say Eddie,
I have a pill right now with no health
consequences whatsoever.
I can give you this pill and you will be
fucking Lebron James Shredded.
No,
I think part of my identity is being
slightly chubby.
Part of your identity has become more
chubby.
Like I'm beyond,
I'm prediabetic so I need to just watch
it.
Sometimes it's some years or something.
Six months ago to Dr I'm prediabetic and
another time for now you're pre diabetic
and you're still eating candy at night.
18 months ago I went to the doctor and
they were like,
you're in the prediabetic zone.
Then I got out of it,
which was good but it's like I have to
watch it cause I'm kind of on the line
and yet you're still eating candy late
at night.
The fuck is wrong with you.
Kind of.
No self control man.
But then you,
you're thinking everybody should get 30
grand.
Do you understand like discipline is an
important part of life?
Do you understand this?
This is very important.
Young Jed.
I am young Jeddah,
I got to get to like full jet.
I status,
man.
I got to work on it.
Just got to,
do you write things down?
Do you write things down that you have
to do?
Yeah.
Do you write things down that you just
don't do anymore like this?
I won't do this anymore.
This is not,
I'm not,
this is not on the menu anymore.
To do that and then sometimes I still
fucking do them.
Well,
you can't do that.
I get to write things down.
That's against the point of writing it
down.
But yeah,
just getting to give yourself a certain
amount.
Like here,
here's a good example.
Give yourself 60 days.
Say for 60 days I'm going to go on a
diet where I don't eat any bread.
I don't take in any pasta.
I don't have any rice.
I only eat healthy foods.
Everything is healthy or I don't eat it.
It's it.
The rice just to kill her man.
Well,
rice is a lot of carbs,
you know,
and it's it directly in your body to
sugar and it'll also,
it's like it's inflammatory,
like it causes inflammation.
Whole 30 thing.
Somebody told me about the whole exam.
It's like no processed foods,
no dairy,
no alcohol.
Whole 30 for what?
Why whole 30 for 30 days?
30 days and you eat like whole foods and
shit?
Well,
I just eat whole foods always now,
but I've been doing it for I t I got on
his primal blueprint diet about three
months ago and I said I was going to
give myself two months,
but after the two months we're over.
I'm like,
this is amit now this,
I feel so good.
Do you drink?
You don't.
Okay.
I don't get crazy.
But occasionally I do.
I believe everything in moderation,
including moderation.
So if you're,
if you're out and you get your freak on
and someone says you want to do shots,
you're like,
fuck yeah,
let's do this.
Get in there.
But you don't do it all the time.
Every now and then.
But I understand the consequences.
You will get wrecked,
you know?
But also Chow Maine on a curb like three
weeks ago,
that wasn't,
that wasn't awesome.
Let's do it.
Drinking,
drinking,
well,
booze is bad,
but the feeling is great.
I think there's some amazing things that
are accomplished when you're under the
influence and incredible things get
accomplished.
I puked shall remain on a curb,
but as far as like social things,
you have real great fun with your
friends that you'll never forget.
There's there's moments of like,
ah,
there's,
there's moments during alcohol
intoxication where you kind of see
things from what they are cause the,
the veil that's in front of your mind,
the veil of inhibition and struggle and
bullshit and insecurity is removed by
that.
Alcohol for the most part,
alcohol makes people a lot of,
it makes a lot of people assholes
because?
Because they lose their inhibitions
because they get cocky because they
don't have fear anymore.
It just,
it,
it distorts reality.
Do you get more social or antisocial
when you joined?
More social.
Yeah,
me too.
I get more social.
You're a nice guy,
nice people to become more nice.
But when someone's an asshole,
when they're drunk,
I usually find it's incredibly revealing
of who they're trying not to be when
they're sober.
Like what they're hiding from you when
they're sober and usually is like
revealing of the demons inside of them.
I just get goofy or,
yeah,
I get silly.
I get,
I want to hug people and shit.
Know what?
I laugh.
I'm a silly,
goofy motherfucker,
so that's,
that's what happened.
Well,
I've,
I've had friends that are alcoholics
though and it's,
it's a weird thing when you look and you
see those shark eyes were like,
oh,
Eddie is not there anymore.
Clink.
You know when you mean to use your name,
but you know,
or Mike's not there anymore.
You know,
you look right in their eye and you're
like,
where'd they go?
They're not agree.
Drunks too,
man.
You're like,
they're fucking hiding that shit all
day.
Yeah,
man.
Yeah Dude,
I want a date with this girl.
Went on one day and it was awesome.
It was great.
Had a good time,
a lot of fun.
I was like,
wow.
She's pretty cool.
Next day I meet her at the bar.
She's already tanked up.
She's breaking glasses,
yelling at people.
I was like,
what?
What the fuck?
Just just a few drinks.
It's all,
it took a few drinks and she went loco.
Did you,
I know I ran mass mass.
Sounds like she could have been
incredible,
bro.
Just break a records of the bedroom.
I knew some people that had been in some
trouble and I learned from other
people's experiences.
No,
I've never been a fan of drunks,
especially girls.
I just feel like when you,
if you,
if you're a date with someone,
if you dated drug addict or you did an
alcoholic or something like that,
and man,
the burden of just getting to know
someone,
enjoying their company and,
and being even with each other and
enjoying each other's company,
it's,
it's hard enough to figure out if you're
compatible with someone socially without
this monkey on their back.
Yeah,
someone's got a heroin problem and
you're going to date a girl with a
heroin problem.
Like I have a buddy,
my buddy Brian Cowen,
he's the best,
but he always used to try to clean these
girls up.
He's tried to take him in.
He was the worst.
I used to tell him,
I like get out now and he wouldn't do
it.
And then two years later,
so was he's,
man,
I should've listened to.
You should have listened to me again her
fucking a decade.
I used to tell this guy dating a heroin
addict or not dating a heroin addict and
we'll go with the no,
it's a good move.
Yeah.
But some guys are like,
yeah,
she's just alone and she just needs a
friend and you know,
once it cleaned up,
I mean she's,
well I'll make mistakes that are into
it.
They're into it.
Well that's also,
here's the reality of captain save a
hose.
When you find someone's problems are
greater than your own,
it lets you concentrate on things other
than your problems,
which you are not fixing the voice.
You are a lazy fuck.
You know,
so you procrastinate and people find
really strange ways to procrastinate and
one of the ways they find it to
procrastinate is to create other
problems in their life that take
precedent over the problem that they're
avoiding.
I agree.
I have given the same speech to all.
This is the funny thing.
I agree with you on all the personal
things.
I don't know why my personal views don't
translate to my world views.
It's kind of funny.
I'm a lot of story thousand bucks.
I'm a lot softer with my worldviews than
I am with like people and my brothers
and people that work with me.
I am too.
It's just I believe in a living wage.
You know,
like I'm down with this Bernie Sanders
thing and I love the fact that governor
Cuomo in New York just passed this $15
an hour thing.
The minimum wage going to be 15 bucks an
hour.
It's so funny.
There's someone set up my facebook,
you know,
um,
you think this is good,
this is going to destroy a lot of
businesses.
I'm like,
yeah,
you know what they said that about
slavery.
It's the same shit they said about
slavery,
abolished slavery.
These plantations is going to go under.
Well,
guess what?
You can't,
you can't just have people work all day
for you and not give them any fucking
money.
Yeah.
They have to be able to make a living.
And if your business does not make
enough money to give someone a living
wage to work all week for you,
then guess what?
You don't have to fast forward.
You can't afford to have an employee,
so you have to figure out a way to
either make more money.
You have to figure out a way to get a
better business or operate with less
employees.
Yeah,
that's it.
The only thing that they have to do is
they have the help subsidize a small
midsize businesses to compete with like
the walmarts and the best buys and the
target.
Subsidize how tax incentives and things
like that to the small midsize
businesses because to absorb this new
salaries right now,
immediately the big companies have a lot
more of a cushion in a margin to absorb,
absorb this shit.
What I'm saying,
the small mid,
you have to start adjusting your,
the way you do in business,
the prices,
things like that.
You got to move some pieces around so I
can fix all this shit.
How quick.
Legalize weed.
Yeah.
Legalize weed worldwide.
Everybody would just so we'd know.
Any people who are having a job right
now would make a lot of money just
selling weed.
They would go to Colorado right now.
You know real estate Colorado's up like
19% but you know what's going to happen?
Bleed.
It's not going to be like your neighbor
or the guy downstairs halloween.
It's going to be big companies and then
it's going to be these kids.
No,
I'm all for legal.
I wouldn't say I want to leave us.
They already are.
These people are buying up the rights in
certain states to be the distributors.
That's what those are.
State laws.
You can't have those state laws.
Those are buying up the rights laws.
That's what they were trying to pass in
Ohio,
right?
Jamie and everybody rightfully said no
to it because this was going to be a
monopoly situation.
They were going to just be,
it's legal.
Go,
go crazy,
go sell it.
Sell it like a half baked.
You know what's going on in Colorado is
it's changing the economy.
Colorado,
first of all,
they made more money from taxes this
year.
For the first time ever.
Then they did from alcohol with weed,
more money from weed,
then with alcohol,
which is just fucking bananas.
And they charged 39% the 39% taxes on
weed.
And everybody's like,
who cares?
Who Cares?
Salad.
It's still cheaper than alcohol and
we'll pay it and it's better.
Exactly.
So like something like that could change
and also look,
man,
you can't infantilize this entire
country like that.
You can't tell people what they can and
can't do.
You just can't do it.
And it's a gigantic part to it.
Anyway.
Yeah,
I mean all these,
these restrictions on behavior and what
you can and can't do or a gigantic part
of the problem with the fiber of our
economy and the fiber of our culture.
We've got all these weird restrictions
that are in place that are archaic and
don't make any sense.
And when you accept one thing,
it doesn't make any sense.
Well then it leaves room for a lot of
other weird shenanigans like Ted Cruz
wanting to lock people up for Dildos.
You know about all that shit.
Oh,
oh,
this dumb motherfuckers really close to
being president.
Ted Cruz was trying to pass a law that
would put you in jail for having dildos
pull.
Pull this up,
Jamie,
because this is just one of the most
hilarious things about this dumb ass
that people were trying to force down
the American public's face because the
Republican candidates are all at joke
other than Donald Trump.
No one could get past that guy.
And he's a joke.
No one,
no one.
You can get past that guy.
So the Republicans are panicking.
They don't know what to do.
So they put this fucking Ted Cruz dummy
in not knowing there's a million
different things that are wrong with
them.
The time Ted Cruz defended a ban on
Dildos,
his legal team argued that there was no
right to stimulate one's genitals.
Scroll up please.
In one chapter of his campaign book a
time for True Senator Ted Cruz.
Proudly chronicles his days,
his tests,
Texas Solicitor General,
uh,
posted he health in 2003 to 2008
bolstering his conservative credit.
The Republican president candidate notes
that during his stint as a state's chief
lawyer in front of the Supreme Court and
federal state appellate courts,
he defended the inclusion of under God
in the pledge of allegiance.
Blahblahblahblahblah scroll up to the
the Dildo case.
Uh,
battle concerning privacy and free
speech,
right?
2004 companies that owned Austin stores
selling texts,
sex toys and a retail distributor of
such products challenged Texas law
outlawing the sale and promotion of
supposedly obscene devices and will were
put,
put the thing where he wanted to have
how much it,
you should go to jail for it cause it
was like two years.
Here it is.
Um,
under the law,
a person who violated the statute could
go to jail for up to two years for
selling dildos.
And this dummy supported that.
This is that this is a women's rights
issue.
Real women's rights issue for Dildos for
dudes to be sexist.
I'm saying no,
but I'm saying I hope this is one thing
that women and men can all come
together.
Dildos.
So important.
It's the most hilarious thing because
Dick's are available for anybody who
needs them.
All you have to do is raise your hand,
step outside of your house when you go,
I'm looking for some deck,
have a sign on the side of the road
looking for Dick and someone will give
them,
is going to pull up.
Yeah.
You know,
there's people that stop and like red
lights and they have signs for change.
Even that works.
Okay.
People will give you what you need,
but if you have a sign that says,
I'm looking for Dick and reasonably
clean,
someone's gotta fuck you.
Someone had some old pull up.
Yes.
Anytime.
Anywhere,
any corner.
But people have the right,
the rural right.
They have the right to want a dick
without a body attached to it.
Yes.
Yeah.
Uh,
Dick without a relationship or,
or opinions or even a pulse.
Anything to say.
We want to Dixon Suneemon that off made
out of human tissue.
You want a rubber one?
Yeah.
It's just,
what's this?
Fill this hole up.
Hard body get done.
It's key.
It's just get it done.
But I don't know how I got to that,
but our leadership as a joke,
it's a joke because you can't expect a
person to want anybody that wants to run
this entire country has got to be a
crazy person.
You have to be a nut and it's really,
really shouldn't have one president
anyway because the idea is ridiculous.
So one person's going to be involved in
the all the decisions for the entire
country.
That's preposterous thing too is people
only pay attention like the presidential
race when all of these other things are
going on.
National Senate,
things like it's hard to fucking keep
track of though.
They're all fucking clowns.
It's impossible.
I said it's impossible.
I don't trust any of them.
And what's really fucked up as this is
like the best bot in the planet,
like all the other spots wa all the
different goofballs all over the world.
Like you see what's going on in Brazil.
Brazil,
they're impeaching their fucking
president right now.
The Panama papers,
shit is crazy,
crazy,
crazy loving it.
Tell it,
tell people about if they don't know
what it is.
Well,
the Panama papers is because this is not
getting discussed in the news hardly at
all.
It's some
not enough,
but it's basically people,
leaders of of countries like the British
Prime Ministers,
dad and um,
Brazil,
the,
the Guy Brazil's involved.
But there's a people leaders,
presidents,
prime ministers have been keeping their
money in offshore accounts,
not paying the taxes that they owe in
their country and keeping this money off
the books.
And then somebody gave this information
from a law firm that does most of these
transactions and it's now being
published.
So all the money's being hidden.
Yeah.
An influence.
And it highlights how people are getting
influenced to make certain decisions and
how much briberies taking place and how
does only apply to certain people.
They don't apply to the people making
the laws off shit.
It's shit.
So the best way to fix this is what give
people $30,000.
Yes.
That's just going to keep people poor.
That'd be the best way to keep people
from competing with you.
I'll tell you that.
Give Him,
give him 30 grand.
They're not going to do Jack Shit with
chuck rock around kick rocks.
Fucking drink.
All the people drink oee anymore.
Old English.
Remember those?
No ketones in them.
No ketones and old English and that
stuff will get you fucked up man.
Yeah,
I remember the first time I drank a 40.
Uh,
I couldn't believe how drunk you get.
Yo,
you are you in town this Thursday?
Yes.
We got a premiere.
You want to come?
Where's it at?
Wednesdays.
Ace Hotel.
Downtown theater.
What time?
Uh,
seven.
Eight.
What time is eight o'clock is it?
Yeah,
it's like seven 38 o'clock.
Dan Arrow back from the black keys going
to be here at six.
I was just a dance crib last night.
He's coming to the premiere.
No.
How are you guys doing the show?
This motherfucker supposed to be at the
premiere will be late.
Oh,
Dan Joseph.
Joe Said don't text while you were on
the show to my bed.
So not good for everybody,
man.
Therefore we'll talk afterwards.
I'm not sure.
I'm not trying to beg for him.
You know podcasts.
Well,
you're one of my favorite guests.
Thank you.
It takes a long time to get from here to
downtown.
Yeah,
we're in woodland hills.
It'll take you probably an hour and a
half at six.
Wow.
Yeah.
He's coming in at six yeah.
If you have to leave your shit at seven
you'd have to leave at six so when he's
here,
he would have to leave.
You have to say hi and you have to ams.
So you took Dan from my art books for a
long time.
He probably just knowing what is going
on.
He's a rock and roll star.
Dude probably doesn't know what the fuck
he's doing,
what he does or he thought he was
supposed to be here yesterday.
Then he told me it was going to be here
today and I was like,
Bro,
I'm here today.
How are you here today?
Does he do drugs Thursday?
No.
Nice.
Good.
How's that possible?
He smokes weed.
I don't want to dry snitch.
So I think that's public,
right?
Dry snitch.
That the Angelo Russell Life,
you know what I mean?
Like say and central Russel.
He's the guy that fucking the recorded
nick young talking about other girls.
Oh my gosh.
He lives the drives.
He is Dutch market niche.
Yeah.
And do they ostracized by the rest of
the basketball community?
Yeah,
I should world.
I think the world.
He said he didn't mean to let it get
out.
Right.
It's not,
well,
his words,
he needs to be on the gre.
You need the fucking ground.
This not interested.
I would love to see you and you sit
down.
This is not an investigative reporter,
meaning man,
I don't care.
I'm just like,
don't hang out with that guy.
Put a fucking scarlet Exxon.
I'm mentally,
he should be out of the NBA dry snitch.
Well,
I'm glad people are.
He doesn't get 30 things and in my plan.
Thank you.
That's so nice.
I'm glad people are looking at it that
way though,
that they have ostracized him instead of
like concentrating only on the guy who
was banging other girls,
you know?
Yes,
yes,
yes.
That you're,
you're right.
The priorities are totally,
definitely solid priorities in that
case,
regardless of whether or not the guy who
did the deed shouldn't have done it or
should have done it,
like whatever your opinions are about
changing,
that guy is violating a friendship.
Like that guy didn't tell him that
because he wanted the world to know.
He told them that because they're
friends.
I have friends that tell me dark shit
all the time.
They do when we laugh like pigs and I'll
never tell a soul,
I'll go to my grave with all that
knowledge.
And that's what a friend supposed to be.
Any guy who would do that,
it's a piece of shit.
So I'm glad that the,
the rules and principles of friendship
have overtaken the rules and principles
of monogamy.
Loyalty.
Yes.
Tell me over to the people over the
people you sleep with.
But no,
it was interesting though because that
same week it was,
uh,
this,
this girl Kalani had supposedly,
people had assumed she had cheated on
her boyfriend who was in the NBA,
Kyrie Irving.
Right.
So then it's the Angela thing happened,
but when it was the girl,
everyone beat her up over cheating or
whatever and she actually didn't,
she didn't even cheat with the Di Angelo
Nick young thing.
Everyone was just mad at the Angela,
which de Angelo deserves.
He's the worst person in that week.
But then also I was like,
well if you're going to be mad at
Killarney,
then you gotta be mad at Nikki on,
which just don't be mad at either one of
them.
Cause who fucking cares?
That's the best.
That's my friends also the girl,
I'm assuming it's hot,
right?
She's great.
I love Columbia.
Okay,
here's the problem.
They're guys who can't fuck hot.
Girls are always mad at them.
Yup,
exactly.
We can't fuck 'em no matter of girls who
will see hot girls wish they could be
those hot girls and they're mad at me.
Mad at him too hot.
Girls take more hate than anybody on the
planet because the guys who can't fuck
'em are always going to be upset.
This bitch thing,
she's better than me.
And Blue,
blue,
blue.
And then the was like,
she ain't all that.
Yeah.
And then the scripts girls just take,
take the constant negativity.
Yep.
That's one of the problems with social
media.
Hot Girls get too much heat.
Too much,
way too much.
Nikki up Nikki on needs more heat.
That guy's terrible.
But then when you know,
you know coby so that the guy nick young
ass coby to sign his shoes after Kobe's
last game,
goes up to colby,
would a pair of Adidas d coby takes her
shoes and throw them in the trash.
Doesn't sign them.
Whoa.
I was like,
wow.
I hated coby his whole career and I love
you now.
He threw him in the trash in front of
the dues and threw them in the trash.
Whoa.
Incredible.
Wow.
That's some real g shit.
Just to let you know.
Yeah,
but didn't coby do that shit with Shaq?
He threw shacks.
Shoes in the trash.
In the trash.
Yeah.
Colby is a little bit of a dry snitch to
game recognize game.
That was it.
That was a game.
Recognize game situation.
Dry snitch is my new favorite word.
Yeah.
It's called people that dry snitch.
Another good one is a dusty.
Do you call them a chili pimp with the
Chili powder?
Chili peppers.
You're broke.
Pimp.
You ain't got shit chilies.
You cold outside Chile.
Oh,
you want to go have a warm fur coat?
Nothing.
Chile pimp.
Dry snitch.
Chili pimp.
He uses the bottom.
Sounds cool though.
That doesn't like to be a chili pepper.
No,
no.
Put it.
Can we pull?
You don't want to be a Chili pip gel,
but it sounds cool out there with the
chips are negative at all.
That's like you're hopping on one foot
and your girls happen on the other ones.
Well that's Nicole outside.
Yeah,
I get that.
But I mean it's chilly pimp sounds like.
Oh,
he's just a chili pimp.
Like your Kaiser Guess Sealer Chili's.
Him who was shivering because he only
has one hole in his stable dude in the
mall.
Claimed he was pimping his pimp.
One was big time,
but he ain't nothing but a Chili Pam.
Yup.
That's how I use it.
I tried to see urban dictionary.
So this world we live in here.
Yup.
This is there's an actual dictionary
that gives you,
you could also buy the mug.
You can buy a mug that says Chili pimp.
Oh,
click on that.
We'll see what we've got here.
Does it have,
oh,
wait a minute.
Oh,
I must have the definition on it.
that is so ridiculous.
This is going to be a gift from you.
I can take this month.
I'll get you the chili pepper.
I don't want it.
You don't know?
Yeah,
you do,
Jamie.
I feel like Chile.
We need him drinking out of it at some
bulletproof coffee out of the Chili Pimp
Mug because they're spelling chili wrong
ditching.
We get you a dress.
This spelling Chili,
like the food.
I liked it.
You liked that then that's like fire.
Oh my God.
Look,
look who wrote the definition.
Brooks and bad ass.
Yeah.
Well,
this is one person's definition of
Chile.
Well,
what's a sapiosexual?
A CPO.
Sexual.
The fuck.
Anything that's not a monkey.
Dad's Homo sapiens.
Is that what it is?
Sapiosexual one defines intelligence.
The most sexually attractive feature.
What?
Oh,
this is the urban dictionary.
I want an incisive,
inquisitive,
insightful,
irreverent mind.
I want someone for whom?
Philosophical discussion.
It's foreplay.
I want someone who sometimes makes me go
out to do their wit and evil sense of
humor.
I want someone that can reach out and
touch randomly.
I want someone I can cuddle with.
I decided students,
all that means I am sapiosexual.
You know what that sounds like.
That sounds like a really lonely person
who needs to get the shit together.
Like when we never,
you read like someone's instagram and
it's filled with,
I'm looking for this.
You know,
someone who loves you deeply does not.
Bubba,
and they have this like that's how
lonely fucker.
Just leave him alone.
Let's shoot.
What if Maya was,
uh,
Asiatic,
single Asiatic male seeks ride or die
chick?
Is that,
that's perfect.
I like it.
Cool.
That's funny.
See when it's funny,
it's cool,
but there's,
if you just,
it's just for all them boys out there
listening.
Okay.
And girls too.
If you're lesbians,
if you go to a girl's page and it's all
this stuff about love and what true love
is,
and when you find the one,
you'll know fucking we run from that
person run now because that person's
probably never happy and they just sit
around posting memes about what true
love is and they're going to make you go
to brunch.
Those people like Brunch,
Mimosas,
those Mimosa,
drinking cunts.
Hey,
eggs benedict can suck my dick.
How about that?
Yeah,
no,
that's right.
I want to check out of a mug.
That's what I'm planning to Brunch.
I like girl that never wakes up early
enough for brunch.
Like Shit,
I missed a call again.
You're also an asshole if you got to pay
someone to make eggs,
like just fucking have eight.
If you want eggs on the weekend,
just fucking make eggs.
You can't let,
but sometimes you don't feel it.
You feel like going somewhere though.
You'd see all eat dim sum.
I'll wake up at like two and go eat dim
sum things.
You're racist.
Racist.
I see what's going on.
I don't want to fucking roll dumplings.
I'll pay somebody to do that.
Let me ask you this cause this is an
important,
or even you know like fuck it,
I'll eat,
I'll eat Mexican,
I'll pay to eat Mexican food on the
more,
more racism,
more racism.
This is what I want to talk to you about
because this is a,
this is a big subject is been going on
now.
This,
this term that didn't exist until
recently.
Chile pit cultural appropriation,
cultural appropriation that Rick bayless
guy who's a very famous Mexican chefs.
Yeah,
that guy is taking shit from all these
social justice warrior dip shits because
he,
he makes Mexican food and he's not
Mexican.
He's a white guy from Oklahoma and there
was this whole article about whether or
not this guy who was one of the best
Mexican cooks,
you think he's one of the best.
His food is not flowing.
You tell me.
He's widely recognized as a highly
respected well here.
This is what makes people deep in this
is what makes us upset.
You're a guy like you,
like you're one of those guys that's
deep,
deep in the world.
Whereas like if you came to me and said,
oh my God,
this guy,
I don't want to say anybody's name,
but this guy is hilarious.
I'd be like,
that guy was dog shit.
And he's got writers,
you know what I mean?
Yeah,
yeah.
So he's a guy that like,
look,
his food's not bad,
but it's not great.
It's definitely not the best Mexican
food in America,
but he wins tons of awards.
Is it?
Cause it's white?
I,
I don't think it's because it's
complicated,
right?
Because he's white isn't wrong,
but it's,
it's the Quan.
You remember like in Jerry Maguire that
like the Quan,
the thing with a lot of these shifts
that win these awards,
the food and wine,
best new chef,
Michelin fucking James Beard.
It's a lot of the times because they can
speak English,
they can communicate with the writers
and the writers can write a story about
them.
They're not winning because it's the
best food.
They're winning because there's a story
to write in,
a story to tell.
And Rick bayless being a white guy from
Oklahoma cooking maybe slightly above
average Mexican is a story.
Slightly have water grill.
It's not fucking good.
Wait a minute.
Border Grill though.
You have a bunch of other people cooking
it.
Like what about when he's cooking it?
Wait,
let me check it to his restaurant named
Rick bayless.
I remember eating,
I just don't want to be wrong.
Fuck him.
He's the guy that's got Tara Grill
Frontera Grill.
Where's that at?
I don't have to look.
And he's in the airports now.
You've got all the airport restaurants,
but you know,
it's weird man.
If you're a standup comedian,
okay.
And you open up a comedy club and some
whack ass comedian frontera grill.
Yes.
If you're a standup comedian and you
open up a comedy club and some whack ass
comedian comes to performs at your
comedy club,
no one says,
Hey,
Joey Diaz is comedy club.
Uh,
I went there the other day and this guy
went up and perform.
This guy sucks.
So Joe Diaz must be a bad comedian.
Like if you were going to judge Rick
Bayless,
you would have to judge him by his own
cooking.
Have you ever eaten his own cooking?
Yeah.
You have?
We're at frontera grill.
But were you there when he called it?
No,
I didn't meet him.
But he didn't.
He wasn't there.
No,
but here's the thing on the work,
like it,
it doesn't matter if he's there or not.
It's your restaurant.
That's your name on it.
If somebody comes in a house and has a
bad meal,
that's on me.
I think we're splitting hairs because
this is a restaurant where you're saying
his restaurants.
No.
Good.
That I understand.
But have you ever eaten his cooking?
I mean,
I feel like if you're in the restaurant,
that's his cooking.
No,
no,
no.
Is he cooked?
Have you eaten what he cooked?
I have not sat in front of him and eaten
when he's cooking there.
No.
What the fuck?
This is what,
that's what makes it,
if somebody makes a chef,
right.
You know what?
I caught a bad review.
I was,
I was known for catching this bad
review.
Um,
at Shalia I had a restaurant,
Sam Sifton came in,
I was sitting in the dining room,
I was not cooking and he did not have a
great meal.
And you know what?
I took it on the face and I owned it.
And the thing is,
Rick Bailey,
she doesn't make bad food.
It's just,
it's not for all the accolades he has.
It's not the best.
But also there's a bit of a thing with
food that the literati,
the intelligence,
you,
the blogs,
the magazines,
they're always electing people that they
can tell a story about,
speak English,
have this she,
she dining room.
They're not,
it's not about the food they always
make,
they always talk about the food,
but it's not.
And I think that people of ethnic
cultures from the,
you know,
the background of Mexican food and
things like that,
people get upset when there's somebody
else that didn't live the life,
didn't grow up with.
It isn't the best at
it representing it.
You know,
like if it's going to be somebody from
outside,
he better be the fucking best.
Otherwise get somebody who lived this
life and knows all the history and
identity and culture attached to this
food and let them speak for their own
food.
Part of the problem,
this conversation is you want to talk
about the restaurant.
This guy runs,
I want to talk about him as a chef and
I'm saying you haven't had his food as a
chef.
Now what I've read is that he makes
excellent Mexican food and he really is
a student of the culture and is an
amorous by Mexican culture and Mexican
traditions and he's essentially a
scholar of Mexican food.
I don't think he's done anything wrong.
I want to put that on there.
But you never does anything wrong.
Right?
I went to his restaurant,
but you would have the best one that had
the food,
but you've never had it from him.
But isn't that,
doesn't that mean something?
But you're saying it like it's not as
big a deal.
It's not because in the restaurant
industry,
the things,
if you walk in once you walk in the
door,
that's that man's food.
Oh man,
fuck all that man's food.
I agree with them.
I mean,
it's his recipe.
He's putting his whole thing he created
on the line and going,
he's not cooking it.
I just feel like,
you know,
if you're leaving it to someone else to
do it,
I mean you,
you might've had the bad,
it's like if you're an architect and you
know,
you're,
uh,
you're a a builder of a house and
someone comes along and does a shitty
job building your creation.
Are you responsible?
Well,
if you were supposed to oversee every
single aspect of the construction beyond
him,
cause I don't think he's done anything
wrong.
And this is,
this is the one thing in this discussion
that I feel is unfair to some of these
chefs,
especially the white chefs,
is it's not their fault that journalists
and people want to give them more.
Somebody wants to give him more.
I don't expect them to throw it in the
fucking ground.
You know?
The problem though is,
is the media and the people giving these
awards and the ones selecting saying
this is the best chef,
this is the best Mexican food.
It's really obnoxious to the people of
that culture that are like,
dude,
that's not really representing who we
are,
but now this guy's representing our food
in America,
and he's the one you go to for
information.
Can we your talk,
let me just be honest with you.
No one who goes to restaurants knows
about awards.
No one.
It's so rare that anyone ever discusses
awards,
but it's so a platform.
They give them the platform to speak
from Mexican food in America.
You know,
he's a guy people go to on top chef.
They always bring them in.
You know that,
that you've given him the platform and
you've given him the megaphone to speak
for a cultural fair,
but part of like awards not,
you know,
anybody that wins.
I don't know what the fucking awards are
for food.
I just know when someone's supposed to
be a famous chef.
Did,
that's,
that's the thing is he's been elevated
as the famous chef.
When you have the Aztec Karachi
restaurant in highland park,
that's fucking fire.
Where's the tiny CIF lining?
Hold it.
Say it again.
Uh,
as tech.
It's the Aztec Herati restaurant of
highland park.
What is it?
Um,
they sell her archie's.
They're awesome.
What's a Hirachio?
[inaudible] they're like a,
it's like a man.
It's uh,
I have to pull up a photo.
It's hard to explain.
It's like a corn.
It's like almost like an open faced,
I would explain it as an open faced a
raper what the fuck's in a rape?
It's a corn Masa.
This,
it,
this is not my specialty.
You know what I'm saying?
If there's a child tamale,
no,
it's corn meal.
You kind of have to see it to we bull
liberace,
h u r a c h e but um,
yeah,
see,
okay.
And that,
that's what,
as tech and highland park,
that thing,
it's like flat bread bro.
Tree like flatbread.
You pick it up.
Yeah.
So it's hard to buy.
You cut it,
you cut it.
So it cut eating corn meal on the
bottom.
It's incredible.
You got to have one of these things,
I believe you.
And then,
uh,
also connie seafood and Inglewood is one
of the best Mexican restaurants you'll
ever eat.
Excellent Mexican restaurants.
But,
but my point being,
I was like,
does this guy,
so you think it's deserve it that he's
getting shit because not because he's
the best Max.
Cause he's,
he's getting all these accolades,
not because he's the best,
but because it's easy to write a story
about him because he's a white guy from
Oklahoma and he's very articulate when
it comes to this.
And the people that select the
gatekeepers and the,
the people who speak for culture,
they're picking a guide they can
communicate with easily makes their job
easy and can tell a story that's like
easily disseminate it,
easily disseminated amongst the masses.
And I don't think it's Rick Bayless is
full.
I don't think rick bayless has done
anything wrong.
Like in this context ever.
It's the media selecting him as you are
now the spokesperson for Mexican food in
America.
And it's like this motherfucker,
like if you're Mexican you'd be tight.
Right?
You'd be mad at that.
Yeah.
Well,
so who should be on the show?
Right.
So when we went to China,
I was craving American food.
I was in China for 17 days and I was
like,
you know what,
I miss fucking hamburgers and a salad
and Nachos.
And we went to a place called Deli
Burger.
It was the most popular American
restaurant for ex pats in Hunan,
China.
And we went,
this place had like pulp fiction
posters.
Big Lebowski was interesting.
They had like a Philips like fucking
French dip logo thing in there.
They collected all these American
artifacts.
They bought an Amazon,
we ate their hamburger and it tasted
like Chinese food.
It was hilarious.
This is delicious hamburger,
but it wasn't a hamburger.
It tasted like they had a philly cheese
steak.
And my buddy was like,
he's,
he's from Van Nuys.
He ate it and he was like,
listen,
I have so many friends that are Mexican
or Asian growing up in La that get mad
when white people or people not of the
culture make their food.
And they're like,
this isn't representing us.
This isn't what they said does not map
Mapo Tofu.
This is not a soup dumpling.
This is some chef's creation.
And he goes,
I never understood why they got mad
until I ate this philly cheese steak
cause he,
this is not a philly cheese steak,
this is like stir fried beef in bread
and they should call it the Hunan Hoagie
cause it tastes good but it is not a
philly cheese steak.
And I love philly cheese steaks and I
love hamburgers.
And it's like when you see something
that you love being called something
else and being represented a different
way,
it's upsetting because your identify.
But
Rick Bayless in his defense does follow
traditional Mexican cooking methods and
makes food that tastes like Mexican
food.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
But the thing is is that he's a fan and
he's a degree removed.
And it's like if you're gonna go to a
source,
why not just go to the source?
If for,
for many cultures,
you know,
like Andy Ricker is a really good friend
of mine,
but when people talk about Thai food in
America,
they go to him and he's a white guy from
Portland to Andy's credit.
And he is one of my best friends and I
love him for this.
He puts the names of the Thai people
that taught them things on his menu as
much as he can.
He pushes the credit and he pushes
people towards the Thai people he
learned from,
so they can get it from the source.
But these journalists are fucking lazy.
They don't care.
They don't go talk to those people.
It's harder because it's easier to call
a guy that speaks English and
communicate with you.
But journalists,
they can write one shitty restaurant
review and just take you down.
They have that power and that power is
really intoxicating,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Have you ever dealt with like douchey
journalists that you felt like were kind
of out to get you?
Yeah,
there's a few people that I've done
interviews with in the first five
minutes I could tell they're out to get
me,
but then once they can tell him pretty
genuine and honest and straight forward,
they're like,
all right,
I'll love with this guy.
I'll talk to him.
So no,
I,
I don't,
I would not say that there were people
that were out.
There's a couple,
but I can't even remember them because I
don't care.
Right,
right.
Well it's getting harder and harder to
do that these days too because of the
Internet.
You know,
if someone writes a shitty review,
it's so easy to out that person and
describe what exactly it was going on
behind the scenes and who that person
really.
And I respond on Ige,
twitter,
youtube people have a problem.
They want to ask me something,
I'll answer it.
So I'm kind of,
it's hard to do the hip piece,
the Ami cause it's like my information
is all out there.
Right.
People know they can talk to me.
I got the answer.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
What do you think is the future when it
comes to a tee?
I think like yelp reviews of common
taken away a lot of the steam from a
journalist's reviewing restaurants.
Cause a lot of people when they want to
find out about a restaurant they'll go
to a yelp review.
You know,
they'll say,
oh well look at this four and a half
stars on yelp.
Let me read a couple reviews.
And you read a couple reviews and he
goes,
see what their other reviews are at
other restaurants.
You find out whether or not they're
accurate or that's,
that's disturbing.
When you find someone who's a Shill,
when you definitely can tell that
someone was like hired by that
restaurant to write some bullshit peas.
They only have one review and it's at
that restaurant.
It's super obvious yet.
That's just annoying man.
But I feel people are figuring it all
out.
Like at the end of the day,
the cream rises to the top.
You fucking figure it out.
Right.
You know?
That's why a lot of the stuff you were
saying is choose like hard work pays
off,
you know,
fucking the people who deserve it to get
it,
you know?
That's right.
I fucking do it.
Fuck that.
30 grand a year can't give people money.
Yeah.
So I love like we started this
conversation.
I love the hate because it helps me get
better at like hearing the criticism.
I like to work on my game.
I like to work on myself,
but at the end of the,
I don't hold onto it
anymore because your destiny is in your
hands.
Whatever you want.
You may have to work harder than
somebody else,
but if you work hard,
you can do it.
You can get there.
I genuinely believe that.
What do you like doing better?
Do you like working as a chef and
cooking and owning a restaurant or do
you like doing these tv shows and all
this craziness you do?
My favorite thing is writing real love
writing because I think writing if
forces me to be the most honest with
myself,
I get to work on myself and get closer
to like figuring out what life is about,
like the meaning of life shit,
and not to be Corny,
but I wake up and I think about it and
when I write every morning I get closer
and I'm puling back layers and I love
that.
But cooking basketball,
when I'm,
when I'm playing or I'm cooking,
it teaches me things,
but the place I go to figure it out as
writing.
I love writing.
How often you write?
Every morning I woke up every morning.
I do,
it may not be that much,
but I'll write something to myself.
I write it down,
write ideas.
I have tons of Google docs.
Always Open.
Really?
Yeah.
Like what kind of writing screenplays
books?
Uh,
ideas.
Just,
I just,
I'm always writing.
I always have,
I always have a couple projects I'm
writing.
Like I have a fiction book I'm writing
right now.
Really?
Yeah.
And I'm at work.
Um,
I don't,
I don't want it.
You don't,
it's a,
the last book I wrote was a romance and
it was a nonfiction about my life.
But the one thing,
yeah,
coming out May 31st called Double Cup
love.
And it's about,
I think you might've met my,
my fiance the first time I came on the
show.
I think she came with me first time
anyway,
maybe.
Yeah.
But yeah,
no,
I,
I wrote about it.
It was about my journey back to China
with my brothers.
So I wrote that book.
But I think,
you know,
nonfiction,
it's hard to keep putting yourself out
there in the most honest way.
So I started writing fiction because I
want to write about my life,
but I want to like kind of grounded in
other characters and things like that
and explore it and work through the
ideas.
So it's been interesting.
I've been doing that.
I'm trying to like write fiction.
Wow,
that's interesting.
Yeah.
You've been doing this for how long?
The last six months I've been doing a
fiction,
but I've been writing my whole life ever
since like ninth grade I was in the
writing.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
So you were pretty diverse guy,
man.
You got this.
One of the things I like about you,
you've always got a bunch of irons in
the fire.
Thanks man.
Yeah,
I wrote a screenplay about,
uh,
suicidal basketball player,
like a kid,
teenage kid going through a lot of shit.
So I wrote about some of the things I
remember,
me and my friends going through teenage
years,
put it into a basketball player from
Queens.
So wrote that screenplay.
I'm,
I'm always writing,
like picking up pieces from my life and
creating characters.
What do you use to write?
What would a program,
do you use a final draft?
But I'm farming idiot dude.
I turned into my homie that works at
mgm.
I sent him a screenplay in Microsoft
word and he's like,
this shit is fire,
but you have to put this in fucking
final draft,
you know,
clown,
so can,
is it not,
it's not that easy to convert the,
you have to actually like write the
whole fucking thing out.
You've got to do it again.
He just rewrote the whole thing was
funny.
But when you could have two windows open
at the same time,
just copy and paste back and forth.
So it's not that brutal.
Not too brutal.
Yeah.
I,
I wrote some stuff from final draft,
final drafts,
tricky.
But once you get used to the shortcuts
and how to use the commands,
you know,
but um,
have you had for writing ideas?
Um,
have you ever used a right room?
Do you know what that is?
It's pretty dope.
It's,
um,
a program where you,
it blocks out everything in your screen
except for,
uh,
the writing.
You can't go into your browsers,
you can't,
you don't get any notifications.
You don't do shit.
It just shows you only the writing and
uh,
it gives you a look like,
look at that.
Like that.
That's good.
It's what your screen looks like.
It's just a,
a black screen with green ink and that's
all you get.
See that would,
the green ink would drive me crazy.
But what I do,
man,
fuck him in the terminator,
I get in the zone.
I'm really good about getting in the
zone.
I play one song,
I'll play one song and I'll loop it and
I'll listen to the same song for like 12
hours just over and oh,
what's offer any like,
it'll just be a song that day.
Like I've had like random jazz song or
it'll be like the Smith and Wesson or
Lana del Rey or can't blow.
And I'll just play that song looped for
hours and hours and hours.
And it gets in a trance cause you stop
listening to the song.
It's just noise.
Right,
right,
right.
It's just,
yeah,
I've done that before.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I've done that on airplanes in
particular.
I like to write on airplanes for some
strange good.
You get focused also,
you're positive.
It's like the altitude thing.
Altitude helps makes you positive.
There's like studies,
you do that then it's like you get
euphoria in the air.
When you're that high up,
it's because there's no air up there.
Uh,
rain's falling asleep.
Something,
something,
some shit about altitude.
It gives you,
you for,
this is another great program called
scrivener.
You ever tried that?
You know what that is?
It's a program that allows you to have
like a,
um,
a virtual chalk ball,
cork board,
and it has all these little index cards
and you move around the cork board.
So I'll show you a here.
I've got it open up here.
And when you,
uh,
you could take some of your ideas and he
could write them on these little
corkboard things and then,
uh,
as you,
I'll show you when it loads up other,
Jamie's got it.
Yeah.
So like that.
So it gives you the option to do these
little,
so I got it like here and you put these
little little notes,
like little,
there's little tiny little fake index
cards and you can move these suckers
around on this.
It's called scrivener.
So you write a lot of screenplays,
Huh?
No.
Oh No,
I don't.
I write,
I used to write a bunch of different
stuff,
but now primarily what I do is I write
essays and out of those essays I take
stand up ideas.
I used to ride a lot of blog entries,
but I found out that a lot of those blog
entries would eventually become standup
and it was always like I was giving
people a preview of the standup.
I'm like,
better to write them for myself and then
just steal from them.
Also,
I'm way into,
I used to do a blog too.
I love blogging,
but I'm at a point now where I feel
people are such exhibitionists you do
something.
He just immediately put it,
I want to see what people think.
Read my shit.
I'm like,
you know what,
men,
unless I made a Samurai sword,
I don't want you to see it cause I don't
want to waste your time.
I want you to see the most fire shit I
made and I worked hard on it.
It's worth your time.
That's a good attitude.
Sometimes though,
I like reading people's blogs.
Sometimes someone will write a Bra,
a blog,
and it'll change your day,
you know,
just to change the frequency of the way
you think.
And just for whatever reason their
thought just makes it into your mind and
bounces around in there and it changes
some things.
Yeah.
I don't think it's bad.
The right blocks.
I just think everybody's doing it.
And for me personally,
I'm like,
you know what?
I'd like to be in the lab and just only
put something out.
I put allowed a lot of shit about my
life in the last few years.
So I'm kind of making sure I really want
to share these things now.
Right.
Yeah.
That's a thing about sharing.
You can't unshare you can't unshare
yeah.
And it's,
it's Kinda,
it's,
it's an interesting psychological thing.
This constantly giving yourself up to
the Internet.
Well,
so there's a lot of people that live
inside their phone.
Yeah.
They live inside their laptop and their
phone,
they live in it and their interaction
with the world comes directly through
that.
That's their filter.
That's their condom for,
for,
you know,
intimacy with the world.
Yeah.
It's very strange.
We're going to learn a lot about
ourselves constantly.
And then,
I mean we're always learning about
ourselves,
but I think this internet thing,
it's people are starting to see,
wow,
I put a lot of my shit out there.
Like I'm kind of naked out there.
And then is this really who I am is just
some fucking alter ego.
So I'm interested to see how this starts
to affect psychology and identity.
Well,
it's definitely affecting young kids.
I mean,
young kids today are so much more
exposed and we were,
when we were kids,
it's not even close.
If you're going to high school today.
I mean everything is on instagram.
Everything is on facebook.
Anything that happens,
it's even remotely interesting in
school.
Gets put out there.
Yeah.
I mean this,
this is the world we live in today.
It's very different.
When I was just going to school,
nobody knew shit.
You heard a rumor about some girl across
town that jerk some dude off and you're
like,
whoa,
whoa.
Let me go jerk off and thinking about
that.
But nobody,
you know,
nobody like put it out there in that way
where the rest of the world could look
at it and the rest of the world can see
virtually anything that you put online
today.
It's just a strange thing because when
you're young,
you also don't understand the
consequences.
No.
When you're,
you're talking shit or saying something
or posting something,
you really have no idea what,
what that's gonna do to people.
We look at these things,
it's like,
Oh,
you got 10,000 followers,
20,000 a hundred thousand million,
right?
I don't think it registers like 10,000
people is a lot of fucking people.
Lots of neat.
It's camp.
All you need is one and that one to get
to someone who has 10,000 and that
10,001 of those 10,000 someone in that
group has 20,000 and that person knows
someone who's got 1,000,003
or four steps.
All of a sudden a million people have
seen that.
And then if it's funny or it's crazy or
it's interesting like here's another
cultural appropriation story.
There's this kid who was taken shit from
this girl because he's a white guy with
dreadlocks and I don't know if you saw
this,
but there was this black girl and
there's this college in northern
California and she was given this little
tiny white dude a hard time.
She was just bullying him,
man.
It was gross.
And she was telling them,
you know,
cut your hair.
You have any saying to a friend,
you have any scissors,
I'm going to cut your hair.
And he's like,
why can't I wear this?
She goes,
cause you stealing from my culture,
which is ignorant on her part.
She doesn't even know any better because
the Greeks had dreadlocks,
the vikings had dreadlocks,
dreadlocks.
It was what happens when you have dirty
hair,
when you have dirty hair and it knots up
in these loops.
Anyway,
that video,
someone was filming her bullying these a
little tiny dude and this video of this
black girl bullying this tiny little
white guy,
God,
fucking millions and millions of hits
within a day because people recognize
that and they were disgusted by it and
then people are also tired of all these
self appointed gatekeepers,
self appointed,
but you know people that can tell
people.
One of the beautiful things about
culture is that culture can be shared
and that people can look like me.
I grew up learning taekwondo and and
teaching classes in Korean because I
grew up,
that's what I spent my life doing and so
that culture became a part of my
culture.
It sounded go stealing it or culturally
appropriate.
I was doing it honor and trying to do it
justice,
but people have decided it's another new
way for someone to stand above them and
take the moral high ground and try to
control people's behavior.
Yeah,
I would say this race is a social
construct.
When you're only basis for an argument
is your race versus somebody else's
race.
You got to fucking shitty argument.
Do you know what I mean?
When it becomes something about
intention and we're talking about
intentions and we're talking about like
are you trying to take a culture?
Are you trying to support it?
Fan of this culture,
are you giving back to this culture?
Those are productive conversations like
the one we had about rick bayless.
Look,
dude,
I'm not out here to try to slam dude's
food.
Like I know a lot of people love his
food,
so I'm not saying,
oh,
I know this shit.
I don't know Mexican Pharma,
fucking Chinese guy dear.
I mean like my opinion about Mexican
food doesn't matter.
Shouldn't matter,
you know,
but my,
my opinion about some this appropriation
cooptation stuff is I wish people didn't
have to have a gatekeeper or a tour
guide or somebody culturally similar for
them to try this food or go to this
neighborhood.
I would love if people didn't have to
have a,
she she dining room with like American
style service or a white face or great
article to try this Mexican food.
Like I wish they would just go to the
neighborhood and go to the source.
And then there's no problem with Rick
bayless's food if we're all informed
about it.
It just tough when he,
the point of entry,
well,
cultural appropriation to me is really
when you're pretending you're part of a
culture,
like of a dude pretends he's native
American and starts wearing feathers in
his hair and shit like that.
And like that's a nutty person.
That's real.
That's legit.
Yeah.
Well it's also real cultural
appropriation.
If you're wearing something that's
supposed to be sacred,
like there's certain articles of
clothing and in some cultures are
considered sacred and you're not
supposed to be just walking around on
them,
like,
you know,
um,
what else?
Things calls it a Bindi.
What are they?
Indian people,
Hindu people wearing their forehead,
you know the,
I mean that was like girls were wearing
those things and,
but I think those are supposed to mean
something in certain cultures are like,
and it Kinda,
I get it kind of looks cool.
You want to wear it because it looks
cool.
I get that.
Yeah.
But things get sketchy when you're
pretending to be a different culture or
you're lying about where you're from or
your a lot.
And that's in my eyes,
more cultural appropriation or taking it
to give yourself an identity that is not
yours.
Yeah.
See all that is those just dishonesty.
It's like not a white dude wearing
dreadlocks,
you know?
He's not pretending to not be white or
like that Rachel Dolezal person that was
the NCAA NAACP person in spokane,
Washington who turned out to actually be
white.
Yeah.
That was the most insane.
It was awesome.
And the funny thing is she,
she actually likes doing a great
tensions were like,
yeah,
well she really does love black culture
and black people and she was doing a
great job,
apparently are running the naacp up
there.
She was,
she was insane.
Right.
She was totally insane for was it.
But when I listened to her intentions,
I'm like,
I don't think you're a bad person.
You just really confused.
This is like,
I don't know how you got to this place.
I think some black dude Dichter and to
delirium.
That's why.
What happened?
He just fucked her so good.
She was just running around with tweety
birds flying around her head.
She had no idea what she was doing while
she was doing it.
That's just my thought.
She was a tough one.
Well,
this crazy people out there,
there's,
and there's a broad spectrum of crazy
activity.
You know,
some of it that's logical and some of it
is not.
Some of it,
there's a little tiny white lies and
some of it that's just pretending to be
a different race,
you know?
Yeah,
man,
that's strange.
And in that strange shit is like what
we're talking about before we can all
learn.
Like anybody that tells like little
white lies,
maybe they'll,
they'll watch Rachel Dolezal or someone
else who got busted in some gigantic
cataclysmic lie and go,
oh,
that's why you shouldn't lie.
Oh that's why honesty and integrity are
very important to people because we
communicate through noises that we make
with our face that's supposed to level
out the intent of your mind.
What people also don't realize is a lot
of the times they think that we're
friends with them for the peripheral
shit.
But I think most people like good people
that you actually want to be a friends
did not your friend because you have
dreadlocks.
Did Not your friend because you're aping
are you doing dear friend?
Cause they fucking like you and you
don't have to pretend,
you don't got to pretend you don't gotta
fucking fake.
Just be who you are unless who you are
socks and then he's probably potentially
to on it,
then you got to work on it.
No,
I just pretend to be black.
I'm not doing a move.
Is Orange Spray Tan and dreadlocks and
no.
Yeah.
Well honesty is always better.
And then if people don't like you will
figure out why they don't like you and
improve upon whatever aspect of your
life that needs improving.
Don't pretend.
It's like,
like here's a perfect example of
something that just never works.
Name dropping named droppings.
Always gross.
It never works.
But yet dummies still tried namedropping
there's a lot of people that still think
they'd be,
you know we were over hanging out with
the Tom,
Tom,
Dan last.
Tom Cruise had dan first.
Oh Dan hour.
Yeah,
but that's different.
I brought him up first cause I was
saying that he was going to be here when
I couldn't go to your shit.
We brought up Shane Smith too,
but we're friends too.
We're all friends.
We're all buddies.
That's different.
All you can't,
you can't date name drop someone we're
both friends with.
That's true.
Yeah.
That's different.
That's true.
But to other people listening.
Oh new shit.
So cool.
The worst is when people name drop and
they use saline one name.
You're supposed to know who it is.
Yeah,
we're over Eddie's house.
Who's Eddie?
Eddie Murphy.
What you were just going to say Eddie
and I was supposed to know or it's
somebody famous and they want to drop
the name and they'll say the real name
and you're like,
shut the fuck up dude.
Like for real name instead of like a
it'll,
it'll be a rapper or a DJ and they'll
use it.
Yeah,
I was with,
you know,
like I'm friends with a people.
Oh,
I was at a lawns.
I'm like a track fam.
It's whatever.
Like I also know his real name.
Whatever you want to do,
man drop.
One of them dropped both of them.
Yeah.
What his name dropping.
How does it,
why does that,
why do people still try to do that?
I don't know if it's like a magic trick
that just everybody knows.
It's just terrible.
It's terrible.
It doesn't terrible.
That's,
it doesn't work.
It's like you're playing three card
Monte and you only got one card.
Like,
listen bitch,
it's the same fucking card.
You can't do it.
Can't play that game.
That's super funny.
Shit.
Alright.
Yeah,
we'll just weird behaviors,
man.
It's like we were talking about before,
we learned from each other.
We learned from really great stuff and
we learned from shit too.
We learn from dumb shit.
I learned.
Yeah,
it's a fucking wise men learn more from
fools thing.
Yes.
I'm a man.
I'm a student of fools to,
I'm in the youtube comments man.
Learn from these.
Get in there dude.
Get in there with anonymous 69 two oh
five up your ass.
Whatever their name is.
Still Mass University.
Mm.
Well there's this,
there's definitely,
I mean I'm joking around a lot about a
youtube comments.
There's actually some people that get
involved in,
I mean I go to science pages and uh,
you look at the,
there's some interesting youtube
comments where people debate at the
actual ramifications.
I'm sorry,
I'm,
I'm fascinated by this planet nine thing
there.
They're trying to observe now cause this
is something I've been studying for a
long time that uh,
they'd been thinking it was,
there was very little evidence of it up
until recently,
but that there was another planet
outside the Kuyper belt somewhere
outside of Pluto.
It's one of the reasons why they
declassified pluto was a planet,
but now
I'm there will almost positive.
And there's a planet out there.
They said,
I think that the,
the said within 99% certainty that
there's a gigantic planet somewhere
around four to five times the size of
the earth that is out way,
way,
way past Jupiter.
And uh,
so I was going to a lot of these youtube
videos that we're describing it and then
reading the comments,
the comments were fascinating.
So that's totally different sort of
world.
You know,
people are debating like the
ramifications.
And then every now and then one of the
Zacharias hitch and people would jump in
there and do you know,
Zacharias Itchiness?
Zacharias itching was a guy who
actually,
ironically enough,
predicted this in the 70s,
but he called it the 12th planet because
that's when they thought Pluto was still
a planet.
And then they thought the moon was a
planet.
I'm like,
this is all based on the Sumerian texts.
This is all getting real convoluted now.
But Zacharias Hitchin,
he,
um,
is a biblical scholar.
He's dead now.
But he wrote all these books about this
culture from another planet called the
Annunaki,
and this is transcribing the ancient
Sumerian texts.
The Sumerians were the oldest areas
that's see that thing that he's holding
up in front of him.
That is a piece of a Sumerian art that
depicts these,
uh,
it looks like some fucking transformer
shit.
Well,
it does,
right?
Well,
what's interesting is you see that star,
you see the star,
the sun,
with all the planets.
That is our solar systems,
not just our solar system that has all
the planets and all the right sizes,
which is kind of fucking crazy.
Wow.
Yeah.
And this was 6,000 years ago when a lot
of people didn't even think that the
world,
they thought the world was flat.
Right?
But it also depicted this orbit is what
would they believe is this?
One of the things that the Sumerian
texts describe is this elliptical orbit
of this planet called Nibiru.
And this planet isn't the outside edge
of our sources to mccombs,
between Mars and Jupiter in there in
the,
this Zacharias hitching translation,
I think it was every 3000,
600 something years and that this is
where the Annunaki came from.
And then what they did is they came down
here,
they studied some lower hominids,
they introduced their DNA into these
lower hominids and made human beings.
And so he had predicted this planet
being outside of our solar system for a
long time.
It's different lies there.
Yeah,
it is there the oil,
it's on this planet.
The orbit is different.
The,
the,
the size of the orbit is different
compared to what he described.
No,
we don't even have a picture of it.
So we don't,
we definitely don't know what it looks
like.
But the,
um,
the Annunaki as described by Zacharias
Hitchen is the same thing as in the bib,
the Biblical term of the Elohim.
Like there's also some different,
um,
descriptions of these giants that came
from somewhere else.
Like,
uh,
those,
I think the description of what it means
is those from heaven to earth came and
idea is that there's advanced beings
came down here and genetically
engineered human beings.
It's widely discredited by other
scholars of ancient Babylonian and
Sumerian culture,
but fun as shit to pretend and read and
read and wonder,
well,
what if he's right,
man.
But see,
when you do look at some of the stuff
though,
you go,
okay,
well how did they know about the solar
system?
How did they know about all those
planets?
Not only that,
they had the caduceus,
you know,
the caduceus,
the symbol for a medicine.
It's also the double helix of DNA.
And that's what he believes that it
represented.
He believes that the,
that that could do see a symbol that
they had,
um,
represents DNA and that that's what the,
what the ancient Samarian people were
trying to describe when they carve these
things into clay tablets.
They were trying to,
as best they could make some sort of a,
uh,
a rational,
logical depiction of what they are being
told by these,
uh,
these ancient people.
Damn.
So we might have already figured it out
once and then we're figuring out again
or not.
Or there's just a giant have decorations
that look like.
So there's,
there's the double helix,
see,
look at you looking at the double helix
of Dna and then you look at the caduceus
where this intertwined.
You see the top one with it.
Ghettos.
If I was 6,000 years old man and I was
going to design some shit with snakes
6,000 years ago,
it would kind of look like that.
Well that,
but it does look like a double helix of
DNA.
I mean it really is very,
very similar.
It looks like a guy was just like trying
to decorate with two snakes totally on
the tango,
but why does it represent medicine and
why is it still represent medicine today
that could do ceus.
That symbol still represents medicine
today.
It's all when I'm having trump looks
weird shit.
There's also some weird shit in terms of
some of the imagery that they had of the
solar system.
One is one of the most talent because
it's really bizarre that without a
telescope they were able to draw
detailed image of the solar system.
Like how the fuck did they do that?
How did they know that there was that
many planets out there?
How were they able to differentiate
between stars and planets?
How do they know the right number of
planets?
Yeah.
Not only that,
they also had a detailed depiction of
the creation of the moon.
They have to,
you know,
scientists and astronomers,
they have earth one in earth to meaning
that earth was a certain size and a
certain shape in the beginning and then
it was hit by another planet.
Um,
that's also in the ancient Sumerian
depiction of how the universe was
created or how the solar system was
created.
They,
there's a planet called a Mar Duke and
Tmr and uh,
tmr collided with Mark Duke or something
like that.
I forget exactly what the,
but essentially it's earth one in earth
too.
It's the same model that actual
astrologers astronomers use today when
they're describing the earth.
But he thinks these people from the
other planet came here and created
humans.
He does.
He thinks,
well,
he's dead.
He did.
He believed that that's what the ancient
Sumerian texts was trying to describe.
But there's a whole website called sitch
is wrong.com and Cichon is wrong.
Dot comes from other scholars who were
tired of listening to all this,
what they felt was nonsense and they,
you know,
they,
they sort of laid out what they think is
incorrect about his translations.
But at the end of the day,
put the translations aside and you look
in at a 6,000 year old depiction of the
solar system.
It's like,
what the fuck is that?
Not only that,
there's these also depictions of these
enormous people with these little monkey
people sitting in their lap and this was
what he believed was describing the
Annunaki,
these genetic alterations of monkeys of
taking these lower hominids,
introducing their superior advanced DNA
into these monkeys and creating
something that's very different.
Doodoodoo too.
I know we would do it.
I'll tell you that for fuck shore,
right?
If we found another planet,
there was a bunch of dumb monkeys on.
He did a detailed like audit of the
planet and found no higher animals.
Nothing that had a computer,
we would drop our seeds.
I mean,
we'll probably already looking for those
places to just,
yeah,
for sure.
At the very least,
I won't fuck one of those things like
Avatar.
Right.
That was like one of the most realistic
things about Avatar that that dude
wanted to fuck one of those blue people.
I would be scared to put my dick in a
blue person.
Yeah.
You never know what's going on in there.
I don't know,
man.
That's fucking,
that shit probably burns through
condoms.
Especially if they leunig blue people.
There's so much bigger than us.
Yeah,
and like,
you know,
especially when you look at the mating
habits of things that we know on earth.
What does this 36 foot five dog and
skeleton so that away,
what are you going above top secret dot
cops foot tall blue person.
Well,
if you do,
you're going to need some help.
You got,
you're not going to do it alone.
36 foot tall.
That shit is so not real.
Well,
it says it's fun.
Most of it,
it's fun.
But if you look at that,
uh,
that image that you had pulled up before
Jamie,
there's an image of one of those
Annunaki having a person having a
little,
a monkey like person sitting in their
lap sign on this page is before when you
had a look at some of those other
images,
there's a,
these ones where these guys,
these enormous looking characters have
these little tiny monkey people with
thumbs and their feet and they're
sitting on this guy's lap,
death thumbs on the feet and the
drawing.
Yeah,
they're,
they're smaller and they have thumbs on
their lap and according to the text,
this guy described it.
The text is very confusing too because
it's something called cuneiform and
cuneiform.
It's like if you ever been in an old
building that has like those old school
nails,
do you know what those old school nails
look like?
Like in the turn of the century,
they were like a flat top,
but it was almost like a wedge and
that's what nails looked like.
Oh,
that's how they,
that was their writing.
That's not that Jamie,
but that's,
that's one of them.
That's similar though.
But this is a Gypson.
You're looking at something that's
Egyptian.
Um,
but the Annunaki one,
uh,
you had had it from just,
if you go back to that window that you
had before,
go back to that window that you had
before that had the depiction of the
solar system on that one.
Okay.
Yeah,
because when you would win whatever
search that you use for that,
there was one of them that had one of
those home boys had one of them sitting
on his lap.
All right up there.
Right up there at the top.
You'll see right there.
Bam.
See that?
Oh,
look at that.
The thumb foot.
Yeah.
It's,
there's a few of these that have a
little weird that people think are
depictions of things with tails.
It's very strange stuff,
man.
It's very strange.
At the very least,
they had an advanced knowledge,
like a Tele Toby.
The one he's holding up Kinda looks like
a teletubby.
Well,
it doesn't look like a monkey in that
picture,
but in some of them they have,
they actually look like they have tails
and got the fuck boy not haircut too.
There's all sorts,
there's all sorts of weird stuff
involved in it.
Their knowledge of the solar system was
one of the most disturbing things
because you're talking about 6,000 years
ago.
Like how did they know about all those
planets?
How did they know that they were,
uh,
they,
they knew the right orbit.
You know,
they knew that Jupiter was like far
larger than Mars.
They had more smaller than earth.
They had like all the orbits.
Correct.
It was a really strange stuff.
It,
it's too good to be a coincidence.
But then I'm like,
I dunno if I believe the whole Shebang,
you know,
almost always the whole Shebang is
wrong,
but it would be awesome if somebody just
showed up on this planet.
Like optimus prime one day was like,
Hey,
I created you guys.
We've been over here.
Like,
Oh,
I've been wondering where you guys were.
What'd you think that that would be fun
though.
It would be awesome.
Isn't it better to be at the top of the
food chain then?
Could we waiting for galactic overlords
to tell us how much we suck?
It would just be,
it would.
It would be just awesome if somebody
showed up like,
this is what life's about.
This which is supposed to do at a year.
Fucking ideas are terrible.
I'm pleased fucking do this.
It would be devastating to the self
esteem of people living on earth.
I'll tell you that because it would
realize we'd be like very lord of the
flies asked like we were a bunch of kids
left alone to our own devices and then
when the adults showed up,
they're like,
what the fuck are you doing here?
You realized everybody was just acting
like a psychopath because they have no
one to look over them.
It would be cool though if if that,
if I've been doing it all wrong,
I kind of want to know what the hell
we're supposed to do,
what we're definitely doing it all
wrong,
but I think we're supposed to figure it
out on her own.
I mean,
look,
if we've got Ted Cruz,
Donald Trump,
Hillary Clinton,
and Bernie Sanders is their only hopes
to be the commander in chief for the
greatest army the world's ever known for
fuck.
Sure we doing to now.
We're 100% doing it wrong.
This is,
these are not the great scholars and the
great intellectuals that we need to help
run this world.
There's no one amongst them.
That has like a,
a brilliant philosophy.
Even when you're looking at,
you're looking at Bernie and Hillary and
Bernie,
as much as I love him,
as much as I love some of his ideas,
you see that guy and Hillary and they're
bickering back and forth on during these
debates.
That's so unbecoming of someone who's to
be the president.
The leader.
Yeah.
Especially a dude who's in his sixties
and some lady you,
you know,
she covers everything except the very
top of her neck.
I mean,
it's bizarre.
It's bizarre.
Like you're supposed to be further along
in this crazy journey than us.
If you want to be.
The president used to be so far ahead
that you have some lessons that you can
impart upon the rest of us.
You have some ideas about how we can
improve our policies.
You have some ideas on what laws that we
can establish that would probably better
to protect us from greed and from evil
corporations and from people that are
raping the world of all its natural
resources.
All those ideas.
Well,
the thing is to really smart people,
do they have other ways to control and
fucking rule the planet?
You know,
like,
I don't think the president is actually
the most powerful person.
You go on Illuminati on me,
right?
Number?
I think so.
Do you believe in the Illuminati
Illuminati?
But I just think that,
I mean if for some of these people that
what I like Michael,
like Bloomberg,
why would bloomberg one,
Bloomberg can already fucking close
shots from where he's at.
He has more money than fucking anybody.
Well,
maybe he feels like the system is broken
and he's in a potential,
he's in a situation to give his life
meaning and maybe enhance the lives of
other people by helping.
I don't know cause I don't know him.
I'm not even familiar with him,
but I'm just playing devil's advocate.
Yeah,
I have advocate would say that that,
I mean,
if you have all that money and you have
all that freedom,
why when you try to make the world a
little bit of a better place.
Yeah,
I agree.
But I think that they can do it in a
different way.
I mean,
look,
the Koch brothers,
I mean,
they're using their means to mold the
world the way they see it.
I think the people who really have
power,
they're like looking at the presence.
Like that guy's a puppet,
you know?
Well,
it's definitely been shown to be a
puppet more than once.
More than one different administration
has been shown to be completely at the
influence of the people that got them in
the office in the first place.
Yeah.
That's all disappointing,
you know?
And that would all be wiped out of the
Annunaki showed up at a gigantic gold
disc came out,
levitating telling us how stupid we are.
We need the Annunaki to come from,
but we're going to be that someday.
That's my thought.
Captain.
Save a hoe.
Save these.
That's well,
yeah,
they would totally be captain.
Save a hoe.
The rest of the other islands where like
pitch,
what are you doing here?
Get the fuck off earth.
You're going to earth these head,
this planet of the heroin addicts.
Have you not watch TV,
have you not gone on earth and look at
the youtube comments.
They're fucking savages.
Get out of there man.
They're going to eat you and fuck you.
Lucky and not necessarily in that order.
They're going to come on your tits,
Bro.
Dude,
run.
They're going to come and your grandma's
Ted's get out.
Get out of that planet.
If someone could be the first person to
fucking on and Aki,
you know,
think that would,
that would be a contest.
That'd be a radios.
Contests like morning zoos between
humans and our Nike's.
It's not a human fucking nine o'clock.
It would be the Annunaki fucking the
human.
You say that.
But what if it's is through a walmart,
clever,
crafty person and an on and Aki that's
been getting $30,000 a year and really
doesn't have any motivation.
And their weak.
I think even the shittiest out of knock
is going to fuck a human through a wall.
I used say that that brick wall,
you see that,
but take one of the dumbest people today
and put them in a room with one of the
smartest people from ancient Rome and
who would be running shit,
smartest dude information Rome.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
Well don't you think that'd be the case
as far as like a advanced intelligence,
like if you get a really dump,
I mean unless they figured out a way to
eliminate stupidity,
which it seems like you're always going
to have conflict and resolution that
seems like what the universe is supposed
to be all about.
The universities all be all is about
problems and solutions for those
problems and that's how things advance
and that's what the universe of of
thought is in this world.
It's always constant conflict and
resolution of that conflict and and
trying to figure out how to never have
this conflict again and what's the best
way to get even natural disasters and
all these things.
There are opportunities to innovate,
are opportunities to figure out a way.
Okay,
we saw what happened in Fukushima,
how do we get power and not have this
problem and what do we do,
and then all these minds converge and
they try to figure out solutions.
I think that's just always going to be
the case.
I think that's always good.
That's,
that's what causes things to improve is
this constant battle.
If everything was groovy and perfect,
nothing would get done.
Yeah.
It seems like you're always has to have
struggle.
Yeah.
There's a dilemma that always has to be
addressed,
which is still,
it gives you his dope.
We end on that.
Yeah.
It sounds fucking dope.
It's good.
Tell everybody about your show.
Where can they get it?
When can they get it and tell everybody
about your book.
April 28th viceland Wong's world comes
out.
You can't get to Jamaica episode.
It's going to be incredible.
The book,
they'll be a couple of May 31st I went
back to China when my brothers brought a
white woman with me.
Oh,
sorry.
Shit Credible Eddie and you could follow
Eddie on twitter.
It's Mister Eddie Wong and on instagram
it's the same.
Right?
Mr Eddie Wong.
Thanks for having me,
my brother.
Anytime that's club in the world.
Oh my friends.
Even on auto rocky planet.
I'm sure it's better than any
unoccupied.
I think they might have a speed.
All right.
We'll see you guys on Friday and I'll
see you guys tomorrow night for 20 in
seattle.
Two shows that the more theater,
how do you think.